bonjour à toutes et à tous monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
commençons cet après-midi l'examen du
PLF
2024 avec la mission enseignement
scolaire cet examen nous donne
l'occasion d'entendre pour la première
fois dans notre commission le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse que je remerci de sa
présence parmi nous comme l'année
dernière notre commission a désigné deux
rapporteurs pour avis sur la mission
enseignement scolaire Monsieur Philippe
fé et Monsieur Christophe Marion la
partie budgétaire de leur projet de
rapport pour avis a été adressé hier aux
membres de la commission ils ont en
outre consacré la plus grande partie de
leurs travaux au thèmes qu'ils ont
choisi le bien-être à
l'école donc quelques petits mots de
rappel sur l'organisation de nos débats
puisque cette organisation sera la même
pour l'examen des autres missions
budgétaires donc après la présentation
des crédits de de la mission par le
ministre je donnerai la parole au
rapporteurs pour avis donc 5 minutes
chacun puis aux orateurs des groupe pour
4 minutes chacun avant de rendre la
parole au ministre pour une réponse
globale à ses interventions et enfin je
donnerai la parole au commissaire qui
souhaite poser une question de nature
budgétaire pour une minute ensuite on
est nous examinerons les amendements et
voterons sur les crédits après le départ
de Monsieur le Ministre et donc ce soir
nous allons continuer de 21h30 à minuit
et si nécessaire nous finirons cet
examen demain à partir de 15h et comme
nous avons près de 200 amendements à
examiner je vous invite par avance tous
à respecter les temps de parole monsieur
le ministre vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés il m'est bien
entendu impossible d'aborder cette
première audition au sein de votre
commission sans évoquer au préalable
l'attentat islamiste de vendredi qui
nous a tous profondément ébranlé
l'assassinat sauvage et barbare de
Dominique Bernard est un choc immense
pour nos professeurs pour l'ensemble de
notre communauté éducative mais bien
au-delà pour nos concitoyens et pour la
nation tout entière je partage tout de
ce choc tout de cette émotion tout de
cette douleur avec les Français qui 3
ans après Samuel Patti voit à nouveau
tomber l'un de nos professeurs et je
comprend prend également l'appréhension
de nos équipes enseignantes et de tous
ceux qui font vivre nos écoles de retour
dès hier pour préparer la reprise des
cours pour tenter d'aborder
l'inexplicable évoquer l'horreur et
malgré tout continuer à transmettre
inlassablement nos valeurs républicaines
hier la France était en communion avec
ses professeurs ce respect cette
admiration cette reconnaissance des
Français nous devons les renouveler
chaque jour envers nos professeurs car
l'école est précisément tout ce que
rejettent nos ennemis tout ce cahï ces
marchands de haine et de terreur un lieu
d'émancipation un lieu d'élévation pour
tous un lieu de mixité un lieu où des
femmes et des hommes transmettent le
meilleur de la création et du génie
humain aux nouvelles générations un lieu
où les jeunes filles quel que soi les
stéréotypes qui trop nombreux demeurent
encore peuvent devenir ingénieur un lieu
où les jeunes garçons quel que soit leur
origine et leur parcours peuvent
s'élever dans la société et épouser la
culture de notre pays un lieu où la
jeunesse de France et ses professeurs
chaque jour démontre que le débat
l'esprit critique
la transmission des savoirs sont les
fondements d'un progrès durable dans nos
sociétés l'école c'est tout cela au fond
l'école c'est une condition de la
République c'est la promesse de la
République jusqu'au bout et c'est parce
que l'école est l'exacte inverse du
monde que voudrai nous imposer les
terroristes que celle-ci ne doit rien
céder renoncer à rien rien amputer de sa
promesse et de son idéal hier encore
notre école s'est tenu debout
aujourd'hui notre école se tient de
nouveau debout et derrière elle c'est
toute une nation qui est unie et fier de
ses professeurs disant cela je n'ignore
rien des débats légitimes que nous
aurons sur les circonstances de cet
attentat mais aussi sur les moyens de
renforcer encore la sécurité de nos
personnels et de nos écoles et
établissements scolaires je pense que
c'est aussi important que nous monttrons
que nos institutions fonctionnent et que
le débat démocratique se poursuit je
pense que dans le projet des terroristes
des islamistes il y a aussi la volonté
d'éteindre le débat démocratique et le
fonctionnement de nos institutions sur
la question de la sécurisation de nos
établissements qui est aussi un enjeu
budgétaire après les attentats de 2015
un diagnostic avait été réalisé dans
chaque établissement et des travaux de
sécurisation engagés au regard des
besoins compte tenu des circonstances et
alors que ces travaux relèvent des
collectivité territoriale vous le savez
au titre de leur compéten sur le bâtis
scolaire l'État a apporté depuis 2017
plus de 100 millions d'euros de
cofinancement pour la sécurisation
d'établissements publics locaux dont les
écoles dans le cadre du fond
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquence le FIPD dont je signale
qu'il est porté par le budget du
ministère de l'Intérieur et non le
budget de l'enseignement scolaire que
nous examinons aujourd'ui pour dresser
un bilan de ces travaux et évaluer les
besoins supplémentaires en équipement ou
en moyens humain j'ai lancé sans délai
une enquête flash auprès de nos écoles
collèges et lycées dont les conclusions
me seront remises en début de semaine
prochaine j'ai reçu ce matin les
organisations syndicales de l'éducation
nationale je recevrai demain les
associations d'élus le président de la
République et la première ministre nous
sont également réunis à nouveau hier
avec mes collègues ministres de
l'Intérieur et de la justice c'est
l'ensemble du gouvernement de la
représentation national à travers vos
missions de contrôle et bientôt le débat
budgétaire des collectivités locales et
des organisations syndicales qui
contribueront à élaborer les meilleures
réponses pour la sécurité de nos élèves
de nos personnels et de nos
établissements scolaires d'ors et déjà
le plan Vigipirate a été réhaussé à son
plus haut niveau urgence attentat avec
7000 militaires de l'opération
sentinaire sentinelle des centaines de
milliers policiers et gendarmes en
patrouille renforcé un millier de
personnel de sécurité de l'éducation
nationale pour assurer une vigilance
maximale aux abord et dans nos
établissements scolaires à cette réponse
d'urgence nous apporterons des réponses
en profondeur et durable pour garantir
la sécurité de nos professeurs de leurs
élèves et de l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative mesdames et messieurs c'est
dans ce contexte que vous examinerez
dans quelques heures le budget pour 2024
de notre école ce budget c'est le fruit
du travail de nos concitoyens qui par
leur impôts finance et rendre possible
un meilleur avenir pour les jeunes
générations à travers l'école depuis
2017 nous avons fait le choix historique
de réinvestir massivement dans l'école
de la République car il n'y a pas de
plus beau message que celui d'une nation
qui croit en son destin et qui investit
dans son avenir en
2024 le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse disposera
d'un budget de 63,6 milliards d'euros
c'est près de 15 milliards d'euros de
plus qu'en 2017 c'est-à-dire une hausse
de plus de de 29 % depuis 2017 la
démographie scolaire a conduit notre
école à accueillir 300000 élèves de
moins et pourtant son budget accru de 29
%. en seulement 2 années de 2022 à 2024
cette hausse atteint 7,6 milliards
d'euros soit plus 14 % j'entends tous
les débats sur les moyens de notre école
ils sont légitimes mais je mets au défi
de trouver un quinquena où le budget de
notre école a autant augmenté sur 5 ans
alors même que la démographie scolaire
diminuait 300000 élèves de moins sur 5
ans 29 % de budget en plus sur 5 ans
en mais derrière ces chiffres il y a des
VI engagement que nous reconnaissons car
nous avons un devoir de reconnaissance
immense vis-à-vis de nos professeurs
c'est pourquoi nous avons porté en cette
rentrée des revalorisations inédites et
sans conditions pour nos professeurs qui
s'élève de 125 à 250 € nets de plus par
mois par rapport à la rentrée 2022 en
début de carrière les professeurs
néotitulaires gagnent désormais 2100 €
net quand ils gagnaient 1700 € nets il y
a seulement 3 ans oui nous avons assez
largement effacé une génération de
déclassement salarial pour nos
professeurs et oui les engagements de la
campagne présidentielle à savoir plus 10
% de revalorisation en moyenne et 2000 €
en début de carrière sont non seulement
tenu mais dépassé avec une
revalorisation moyenne de 11 % entre
avril 2022 et janvier 2024 et comme je
l'indiquais un salaire de départ à 2100
€ net pour les titulaires évidemment en
disant cela je ne dis pas que tout va
bien dans le meilleur des mondes je dis
simplement là aussi que je mets au défi
de trouver depuis
1990 une revalorisation d'une telle
ampleur sur un temps si court il n'y en
a pas depuis plus de 30 ans cela étant
dit le chemin pour odedorer le prestige
social du métier de professeur et
rebâtir son attractivité dans notre pays
n'est pas terminé c'est pourquoi j'ai
engagé dès la rentrée avec les
organisations syndicales une large
discussion sur l'attractivité du métier
de professeur à travers les enjeux de la
formation initiale des évolutions de
carrière et des conditions de travail je
souhaite y associer les parlementaires
notamment de la commission des affaires
culturelles et de l'éducation j'en
rendrai les conclusions d'ici le début
de l'année prochaine je peux d'ors et
déjà vous indiquer que parmi les pistes
de réflexion abordées par les
organisations syndicales se dégage de
puissant leviers d'attractivité à
travers un nouveau positionnement du
concours pour une meilleure formation
initiale en master un meilleur
accompagnement à la prise de poste des
conditions de progression amélioré au
milieu de carrière un effort accru de
prévention en santé ou encore
l'aménagement des fins de carrière
au-delà de ces revalorisations
historiques le PLF 2024 porte aussi
l'ambition de continuer à réduire la
taille des classes pour nos élèves avec
l'achèvement du dédoublement en grande
section de maternelle en Rep et REP plus
dès la rentrée 2024 je rappelle que nous
sommes à 85 % en cette rentrée nous
serons à 100 % à la rentrée 2024 nous
passerons de 23,6 élèves par classe en
moyenne en 2017 à 21,4 en moyenne en
2024 dans le premier degré à la rentrée
2024 nous pourrons ainsi dire qu'aura
été achevé le dédoublement de classes de
grandes sections CP CE1 au bénéfice de
500000 élèves en éducation prioritaire
cet investissement là aussi massif et
inidit de la nation qui représente 11000
créations de postees de professeurs des
écoles a déjà produit et continuera de
produire des résultats une étude de
septembre 2021 de la direction de
l'évalu de la prospective et de la
performance montrer ainsi que le
dédoublement permet en fin de CE1 de
réduire de 15 à 40 % les les écarts en
lecture et en calcul entre un élève en r
plus et un élève hors éducation
prioritaire réduire les inégalités
scolaires en élevant le niveau de tous
en ivlant par le haut en quelque sorte
c'est bel et bien l'objectif que nous
devons poursuivre ce PLF 2024 finance
également la création de 60 très petites
sections supplémentaires accueillant D 2
ans en quartier politique de la ville
les créations de postes en uliss ou la
poursuite du Plan Autisme ce PLF 2024
permet aussi à l'école de la République
de poursuivre son ambition d'accueillir
tous les enfants de France à travers le
service public de l'école inclusive
depuis 2017 nous avons
recruté 51 % d'accompagnement d'élèves
en situation de handicap de plus et
accueilli en milieu ordinaire 36 %
d'élèves en situation de handicap de
plus en cette rentrée ce sont ainsi plus
de 475000 élèves en situation de
handicap qui sont scolarités dans nos
écoles c'est une fierté mais pour que
cet accueil soit satisfaisant nous avons
besoin de davantage de moyens humains je
le disais depuis 2017 nous avons
massivement augmenté le nombre d'aesh
qui accompagneent ces élèves notre école
compte aujourd'hui 130000 aesh qui
interviennent dans nos classes en
quelques années le métier d'aesh est
ainsi devenu en nombre de personnel le
deuxème métier de l'éducation nationale
l'année 2023-2024 marquera la poursuite
de cet effort avec le recrutement de
4000 1800 à es supplémentaire soit 15000
à es supplémentaire par rapport à 2022
mais je n'ignore évidemment là aussi
rien des difficultés qui demeurent je
n'ignore rien des délais je n'ignore
rien des manques qui persistent je
reçois les témoignages souvent
bouleversants de familles qui attendent
une aesh pour leur enfant je veux leur
dire que pour recruter plus nous avions
besoin de revaloriser et de déprécariser
le métier d'AES en cette rentrée les
aesh gagnent de 89 à 117 € net de plus
par mois grâce à l'amendement adopté
l'an passé en PLF 2023 les aesh
bénéficieront aussi en ce mois d'octobre
d'une prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir
d'achat qui leur sera versé à hauteur de
500 € en moyenne alors qu'il y a 6 ans
la plupart des aesh étaient en contrat
aidé extrêmement précaire plus de 55 %
des aesh sont désormais en CDI et
bénéficient d'une meilleure formation
même si bien sûr nous devons encore
progresser enfin nous devons permettre
aux aesh qui le souhaitent de travailler
sur un temps comp PL et nous avons d'ors
et déjà conclu avec plus de 80
collectivités des conventions en ce sens
pour aller plus loin et pour répondre
aux perspectives ambitieuse fixée par la
dernière conférence nationale du
handicap ce PLF propose en son article
53 une expérimentation à travers la
création de pôle d'appui à la scolarité
les passes qui vise à donner une réponse
pédagogique plus rapide et plus complète
aux élèves en situation de handicap et à
leur famille ces pôles d'appui à la
scolarité que je veux expérimenter dès
la rentrée 2024 dans plusieurs
départements doit permettre d'améliorer
sensiblement leurs conditions d'accueil
et de scolarisation en leur raortant
avec des personnel dédié une réponse de
premier niveau élaborée conjointement
par des professionnels de l'éducation
nationale et du
médico-social voilà des années que de
telles coopérations étaent légitimement
demandé au bénéfice des élèves en
situation de handicap à présent nous
souhaitons les engager très concrètement
ces pôles d'appui à la scolarité seront
chargés d'abord de déf définir et
d'assurer la mise en œuvre rapide des
mesures cohérentes avec l'évaluation des
besoins de l'élève il s'agisse
d'adaptation pédagogique de mise à
disposition de matériel pédagogique
adapté nous devons réduire très
sensiblement les délais de
l'intervention de personnel de
l'éducation nationale mais également et
c'est nouveau comme je le disais de
personnel
médicaux-sociaux ils doivent permettre
ensuite d'informer les familles de la
possibilité de saisir la mdphage d'une
demande de reconnaissance de handicap et
de compensation et de les conseiller et
de les accompagner dans ces démarches
ils doivent permettre enfin d'apporter
leur appui en matière de ressources de
pratique pédagogique et de formation au
personnel des écoles et des
établissement de leur ressort qui en
font la demande mettre toutes les
expertises autour de la table apporter
une vraie réponse complète et rapide aux
familles aux élèves et à leurs
professeurs avec ces pôles d'appui à la
scolarité et les 300 recrutements qui
les feront vivre 100ans sur mon budget
et 200 sur le budget du médico-social
nous avons le pouvoir d'opérer un
véritable saut qualitatif et
accompagnement pour l'accueil de tous
les élèves à l'école de la
République j'ai parlé de moyens humains
cela vaut pour l'accompagnement des
élèves en situation de handicap mais
cela vaut aussi pour la lutte implacable
que nous devons mener contre ce fléau
qui est le harcèlement scolaire je l'ai
dit dès ma prise de fonction la lutte
contre le harcèlement est ma grande
cause pour notre école je sais pouvoir
compter sur votre très large soutien
pour combattre ce fléau par-delà
l'éclivage politique car on apprend pas
bien à l'école quand on y est malheureux
on n apprend pas bien les savoirs
fondamentaux quand t son esprit est déjà
préoccupé par une situation de
harcèlement voilà pourquoi nous avons
annoncé avec la première ministre un
plan
interministériel de lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire et le
cyberhcèlement pour l'éducation
nationale il s'appuiera sur des moyens
dont nous disposons déjà au sein du
budget 38 millions d'euros par an qui
permettent de financer les formations
des personnels mais aussi une partie des
missions des référents au sein de nos
établissements toutefois nous devons
dégager des moyens supplémentaires à
deux titres d'une part pour le
recrutement des équipe académique dédié
à temps plein à la lutte contre le
harcèlement qui pourront assurer un
traitement et un suivi systématique de
chaque situation et je le dis un suivi
humain après malheureusement des drames
que nous avons connu y compris en
matière de réponse qui pouvaient être
apporté par l'administration à certaines
situations d'autre part ces moyens
permettront de renforcer notre médecine
scolaire qui en a tant besoin et plus
largement recruter davantage
d'infirmiers d'assistants sociaux en les
rémunérant mieux même si nous avons déjà
engagé des revalorisations substantielle
au cours des dernières années le 9
novembre prochain se tiendra dans tous
nos établissements scolaires la journée
non au harcèlement
elle permettra l'écoute et le recueil de
la parole de tous les élèves elle
permettra d'identifier des situations
qui jusqu'ici restaient sans réponse
elle permettra d'amorcer ce changement
culturel que j'ai voulu conduire à tous
les étages de l'éducation nationale pour
qu'enfin la parole des élèves soit
systématiquement écouté entendu et suivi
des faits enfin le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
joue un rôle fondamental dans la
transition écologique et dans la
cohésion sociale de notre pays car
l'école je le disais est le cœur battant
de notre nation et l'institution qui en
perpétue la culture les valeurs et les
principes en les transmettant aux
futures générations aujourd'hui notre
école compte 100 million et demi
d'élèves boursiers sur critères sociaux
et nous avons revalorisé ces bourses de
6 % en 2 ans leur versement sera
désormais automatique à comptter de la
rentrée 2024 afin de lutter contre le
non recours et parfois l'auto censure
j'ajoute que 150000 élèves bénéficient
également d'une bourse au mérite et
40000 d'une prime d'internat que nous
continuons bien sûr de renforcer les
fonds sociaux sont sanctuarisés à
hauteur de 54 millions d'euros et nous
poursuivons le déploiement des petits
déjeunés gratuit des cantines à 1 €
grâce au Pacte des
solidarités je rappelle que ce pacte des
solidarités est financé par la Mission
solidarité et insertion du PLF les
crédits n'apparaissent donc pas sur le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale l'an
passé ce sont 13 millions de
petitsdjeunés gratuits qui ont pu
bénéficier à des élèves de famille
modestes alors qu'on sait et toutes les
études le montrent qu'on apprend mieux à
l'école plus calme à l'école quand on
appr pris un petit déjeuner que quand on
en a pas pris en cette rentrée 2023 nous
finançons l'extension de la part
collective du Pass Culture aux élèves de
6e et 5e qui constitue l'une des briques
de notre ambition 100 % d'éducation
artistique et culturelle pour l'école de
la République l'an passé 2,2 millions de
collégiens ont ainsi bénéficié du
passculture avec des visites de musées
des représentations théâtrales la
pratique d'un instrument de musique et
je veux saluer les 87 % des collèges qui
se sont déjà engagés dans cette démarche
évidemment notre objectif c'est que 100
% d'entre eux s'y engagent nous
poursuivons comme je l'ai dit
l'investissement dans l'éducation
prioritaire avec l'achèvement du
dédoublement des classes au total nous
aurons créé à ce titre près de 11000
postes dans le premier degré depuis 2017
et augmenté de 50 % le budget de
l'éducation prioritaire c'est aussi pour
financer cet effort que nous devons
discuter de la réorientation
du fond de 42 million d'euros destinés
aux communes qui ont choisi de maintenir
la semaine de 4 jours et demi si les
documents budgétaires qui vous ont été
soumis l'an dernier indiqué clairement
une réduction de 50 % du fond dès cette
rentrée avant une extinction à la
rentrée prochaine nous avons comme vous
le savez choisi de maintenir ce fond en
cette rentrée ce qui supposera de
réabonder de 19 millions d'euros les
crédits du PLF 2024 et de discuter de
cette évolution à comptter de la rentrée
2024 le temps de pouvoir concerter
convenablement avec les communes sur les
nouvelles modalités de financement de
leurs activités périscolaires du point
de vue de mon ministère les marges de
manœuvre ainsi dégagé pour être
utilement redéployé sur l'éducation
prioritaire l'égalité des chances c'est
aussi la réforme du lycée professionnel
avec à terme 1 milliard d'euros par an
investi en plus pour les élèves à
travers la gratification des stages de
la classe de seconde à celle de terminal
les cours en petits effectifs l'ajout de
cours d'option la création de bureaux
des entreprises dans chaque
établissement ou encore la
transformation de la carte des
formations notre objectif c'est de faire
chuter drastiquement le taux de
décrochage et d'augmenter
significativement le taux de poursuite
d'études dans le supérieur et
d'insertion dans l'emploi s'agissant
enfin de la rénovation du bâti scolaire
qui représente la moitié du bâti public
en France et qui relève des
collectivités nous apportons à travers
le fond vert du ministère de l'écologie
un cofinancement puissant de l'État à
hauteur de 500 millions d'euros par an
dédié à la rénovation des écoles la
Caisse des dépôts et des consignations à
travers son programme et du renve et les
dotations d'investissement des
collectivités à l'investissement des
collectivités territoriales du budget de
l'État complète cet effort massif dans
l'objectif de rénover 40000 écoles d'ici
10 ans cet objectif nous devons le tenir
pour atteindre nos objectifs de
transition écologique mais aussi pour la
santé et le bien-être de nos élèves
comme de leurs professeurs je leuraai
dit à l'école de la République on doit
plus avoir trop chaud l'été ou trop
froid l'hiver et cela passe par un
investissement décisif dans la
rénovation du bâti alors même que ça
n'est pas la compétence de l'État nous
mettons 500 millions d'euros par an pour
ce budget ils n'apparaissent pas sur les
crédits de l'enseignement scolaire ils
sont donc à comptabiliser en plus de
toutes les augmentations dont je vous ai
parlé ils sont sur les crédits du fond
vert de la même manière je rappelle
l'engagement du président de la
République à un investissement
budgétaire également de l'État alors que
ça n'est pas sa compétence pour les
équipements sportifs 100 millions
d'euros par an supplémentaires sur les
trois prochaines années là encore ça
apparaît sur le budget du ministère des
Sports et non sur celui de l'éducation
nationale mais c'est là aussi un
investissement inédit en faveur des
équipements sportifs portés par nos
écoles et qui concernent nos élèves mon
ministère finance également le bâti
scolaire à Mayotte où nous engageons 523
millions d'euros d'investissement sur la
période 2024-2027 les projets de
reconstruction à la réunion avec 60
millions d'euros pour le lycée de la
merè et du tourisme vert sur
2024-2028 la rénovation du patrimoine du
ministère avec 96 millions d'euros en
2024 et enfin sa modernisation
informatique avec 180 millions d'euros
en 2024 voilà mesdames messieurs les
députés sans être plus long mais nous
aurons des échanges ce que très
concrètement permet de financer le PLF
2024 pour notre école et au service de
nos élèves et de notre jeunesse je me
tiens à présent à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos
questions merci monsieur le ministre
pour cette présentation du budget et on
voit bien au travers votre présentation
la transversalité de l'école
puisqueeffectivement on fait app à
d'autres ministères pour un certain
nombre d'opérations que ce soit la
transition écologique ou le sport et je
voulais dire aussi que bien entendu nous
nous associons à à vos propos pour
condamner l'attentat islamiste qui a pu
avoir lieu et qui a coûté la vie à aux
professeurs et que nous sommes à côté
des familles et de toute la communauté
éducative maintenant je vais laisser la
parole aux orateurs pour 4 minutes
mais on verra à quel moment il va
falloir suspendre je ah pardon les
rapporteurs avant excusez-moi pourquoi
je voulais ah oui non mais parce qu'en
fait ils n'étaient pas à côté de moi ils
sont restés à leur place donc en fait
les rapporteurs vous avez 5000 chacun
mais je vous aurais redonné la parole
rassurez-vous merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
nous nous souhaitons commencer par nous
associer aux premières paroles de de
madame la Présidente et monsieur le
ministre c'est la première fois que
notre commission se réunit depuis
l'attentat d'aras qui plusé pour évoquer
notre système scolaire nos élèves nos
enseignants nous tenions donc à exprimer
notre solidarité à l'égard des
personnels de l'Éducation nationale et
de leurs élèves et adresser bien sûr nos
pensées aux victimes de ce drame et à
leurs proches nous sommes comme beaucoup
très émus par ce drame en particulier
mon collègue et ami Philippe qui côoie
régulièrement les arageois en tant que
député et conseiller départemental du
pcalé la mission enseignement scolaire
du projet de lois de finance pour 2024
met en exerg les priorités du
gouvernement pour notre école
acquisition des savoirs fondamentaux et
réussite des élèves d'une part mais
également leur épanouissement et leur
bien-être d'autre part pour atteindre
ces deux objectifs le gouvernement a lou
des moyens inédits au budget de
l'Éducation nationale ainsi la mission
enseignnement scolaire demeure le
premier budget de l'État avec plus de 86
milliards d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et en crédit de paiement ce
budget est en hausse de 5,31 % après
l'avoir été de 6 % l'année passée depuis
2022 le Budet du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale augmenté de 13,6 %
et 7,6 milliards d'euros soit une hausse
plus forte en 2 ans que sous chacune des
deux précédentes mandatures nous y
sommes bien évidemment favorables et
appelons cette progression à se
poursuivre dans une dynamique
pluriannuelle pour permettre à
l'ensemble des réformes engagées
d'aboutir cette augmentation résulte
d'un grand nombre de mesures ambitieuses
la première d'entreelle par son impact
budgétaire et la poursuite des
revalorisations des personnels notamment
des enseignants les revalor isation dite
socle inconditionnel représenteront 1,3
milliard d'euros en 2024 elles intègrent
le relèvement des indemnités de fonction
perçu par les enseignants les CPE et les
psychologues de l'éducation nationale la
revalorisation de la prime d'activité
les mesures de fluidification des
carrières ainsi tous les enseignants
titulaires les CPE Les PSI débuteront
leur carrière avec une rémunération
supérieure à 2000 € nets par mois cette
rémunération atteindra 2102 € pour les
enseignants néotitulaires et 2466 € pour
les néotitulaires en r plus s ajoute les
mesures issues du rendez-vous salarial
ainsi que pour les enseignants
volontaires la rémunération de missions
complémentaires au total sans les les
revalorisations liées au Pact les
enseignants titulaires gagneront en
moyenne 258 € net de plus par mois en
janvier 2024 par rapport à avril 2022
soit une progression de 11 %. nous
saluons ces efforts pour améliorer
l'attractivité du métier tout en
rappelant qu'ils doivent être poursuivi
et ne pas se lié à la question salariale
mais également inclure les enjeux
relatifs aux conditions de travail
l'acquisition des savoirs fondamentaux
et la réussite scolaire demeure
également parmi les grandes priorités du
gouvernement il déploie plusieurs
mesures en ce sens le développement de
l'accueil des 2 ans l'achèvement du
doublement des classes des grandes
sections en éducation prioritaire les
plans de formation mathématique français
et maternel pour les enseignants l'UR
hebdomadaire de soutien et
d'approfondissement mathématique ou en
français au collège la généralisation du
dispositif devoir fait ou encore la
réintégration des mathématiques dans le
Tron commun de première générale mais la
réussite scolaire n'a de valeur que si
elle est accessible à tous c'est
pourquoi le projet loit de finance porte
plusieurs mesures visant à garantir
l'égalité des chances et l'accès de tous
à l'éducation le budget consacré à
l'inclusion scolaire des élèves en
situation de handicap augmente ainsi de
15,43 % et permettra le recrutement de
3000 àsh ainsi que leur revalorisation
salariale de 13 % en moyenne s ajoute la
création d'un fond de soutien à
l'acquisition de matériel adapté doté de
25 millions d'euros le financement des
cordés de la réussite des contrats
locaux d'accompagnement des territoires
éducatifs ruraux et de nouveaux
internats d'excellence intégrés au plan
France ruralité contribuera à la
réduction des inégalités sociale et
territorial pour permettre la réussite
de tous le PLF prévoit également les
dispositifs relatives à la mise en œuvre
de la réforme de la voie professionnelle
celle-ci financera en effet le
développement des bureaux des
entreprises des dispositifs tout droits
ouverts et ambition emploi de
l'enseignement en petit groupe mais
également la gratification des périodes
de formation en milieu professionnel au
total 1 milliard d'euros sera investi en
2024 pour soutenir cette réforme portée
par les ministères chargé d'éducation
nationale mais également du travail de
l'agriculture par le Secrétariat d'État
chargé de la mer et par le par le plan
France 2030 l'enseignement technique
agricole fait enfin l'objet d'une
attention particulière puisque les
crédits du programme 143 augmenteront en
2024 de
6,39
%. monsieur F ou merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues au-delà de la seule dimension
quantitative de notre analyse du projet
de budget nous avons également souhaité
nous intéresser de manière plus
approfondie à la question du bien-être
des élèves à l'école condition
fondamentale de leur réussite scolaire
et personnelle le bien-être à l'école
est une notion dont le périmètre nous
est apparu particulièrement difficile à
définir d'autant plus que celui-ci est
nécessairement multifactoriel et que sa
que sa quantification se fait souvent en
creux par ce qui peut être évité
dépression suicide et cetera si le
bien-être ne saurait être considéré
comme dépendant uniquement de l'école il
est incontestable et toutes nos
auditions nous l'ont montré que l'école
a un grand rôle à jouer pour le
préserver voire
l'améliorer les constats récents font
état d'une dégradation alarmante de la
santé mentale des élèves dont plusieurs
études notamment de santé publique
France
atteste nous regrettons cependant qu'un
certain nombre de dispositifs
d'évaluation du climat scolaire dans les
établissements soi
sous-utilisés le sujet du bien-être n'en
reste pas moins de mieux en mieux pris
en considération par l'ensemble des
systèmes scolaires au niveau
international comme national en France
c'est notamment l'un des enjeux du
dispositif l'école promotrice de la
santé qui repose sur l'idée que l'une
des responsabilités de l'école est de
promouvoir auprès des élèves une santé
complète passant par la confiance en soi
les compétences psychosocial
l'alimentation ou encore le sport ceci
mérite d'autant plus d'être souligné que
beaucoup d'auditions nous l'ont montré
la prise en compte du bien-être n'est
traditionnel pas dans l'ADN de l'école
en France la question du corps par
exemple a longtemps été impensée ce qui
se perçoit encore dans le poids d' carta
ou l'organisation des espaces les
mentalités évoluent cependant et
rapidement ce dont nous nous
réjouissons nous sommes parfaitement
conscients et l'ensemble des dimensions
que recouvre la question du bien-être à
l'école baptisco olaire propreté
restauration sentiment de sécurité
évaluation des notations et cetera mais
nous avons choisi de mettre l'accent sur
deux leviers qui nous paraissent
essentiels la promotion de l'activité
physique d'une part et la lutte contre
le harcèlement d'autre part en effet
l'activité physique constitue un élément
d'amélioration du bien-être physique des
élèves mais également du bien-être
psychique et du climat scolaire dès lors
qu'elle permet d'accroître leur
concentration en classe mais aussi de
développer des compétences
psychosociales et sociales comme la
solidarité la tolérance la coopération
ou le as d'autrui initier des activités
adaptées au handicap permet en outre la
construction de projets communs
inclusifs et une meilleure compréhension
du handicap à cet égard les Jeux
olympiques de Paris en 2024 doivent être
saisis comme l'occasion de faire changer
un certain nombre de pratiques et de
sensibiliser les élèves à l'importance
d'une pratique sportive régulière il
nous faudra être vigilant à l'héritage
de ces jeux dans la durée plusieurs
mesures récentes ont eu pour objet de
renforcer la pratique physique des
élèves du 1er et du second degré en
particulier les 30 minutes d'activité
physique quotidienne et les 2 heures de
sport de plus au collège elles
commencent à porter leurs
fruits cependant pour que l'activité
physique contribue de manière effective
à l'amélioration du bien-être à l'école
plusieurs points de vigilance doivent
être mentionnés il s'agit en particulier
d'éviter le sport compétition qui peut
accentuer la stigmatisation de certains
enfants il faut également chercher à
toucher les élèves les plus éloignés de
la pratique sportive et non uniquement
ceux pour lesquels c'est naturel il faut
enfin renforcer la formation des
enseignants en particulier dans le
premier degré car ceci s'estime en
majorité suffisamment outillé sur ces
sujets s'agissant de la lutte contre le
harcèlement nous souhaitons là encore
penser d'abord aux trop nombreuses
victimes et à leurs familles les formes
de harcèlement évoluent et ne se
limitent plus au seul cadre scolaire le
cyberhcèlement a profondément bouleversé
les comportements et les capacités de
réaction de l'administration de
l'administration pardon mais aussi
priver les élèves du moindre temps de
respiration du moindre échappatoire
comme nous l'ont dit plusieurs
associations que nous avons rencontré
100 % des élèves sont aujourd'hui
touchés par le harcèlement qu'ils en
soient victimes auteur ou témoins il
faut donc agir les bons résultats du
programme pH sont assez largement
reconnus mais beaucoup s'accordent aussi
à dire qu'il faut les consolider en
informant davantage les élèves et leurs
familles de l'existence de ce dispositif
en formant mieux les enseignants et
surtout en développant des temps de
concertation entre professionnels
l'éviction du du harceleur d'un
établissement est une bonne mesure mais
elle devra s'accompagner de mesures
éducatives sous peine de ne conduire
qu'à déplacer le problème le plan
interministériel visant à mieux prévenir
mieux détecter mieux répondre au
harcèlement promet des avancées en la
matière dont nous suivrons la mise en
œuvre avec attention nous insistons en
particulier sur l'importance du
développement des compétences
psychosociales dès le plus jeune âge les
cours d'empathie qui ont été évoqués
peuvent être une piste intéressante et
nous avons entendu à cet égard un
certain nombre d'organismes et de
propositions à étudier il faudra en tout
état de cause en préciser les contours
et modalités et nous souhaitons vivement
que l'ensemble des personnels soit
associé à cette réflexion en particulier
les médecins les infirmiers et les PSI E
nous serions ravis monsieur le ministre
de vous entendre sur ce dernier
point merci monsieur le rapporteur je
vais laisser la parole maintenant pour 4
minutes à Quentin
bataillon c'est bon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre messieur
les rapporteurs chers collègues cette
présentation de la mission budgétaire
relative à l'enseignement scolaire
s'inscrit dans un contexte extrêmement
douloureux députés de la République nous
étions tous Hier présents dans nos
circonscriptions afin de soutenir le
corps enseignant et l'ensemble du
personnel de l'éducation nationale
c'estes combattants du savoir comme vous
le dites si bien monsieur le ministre
nous rendons hommage à Samuel Patti à
Dominique Bernard à toute notre école
endillée et profondément bouleversée
face à tant d'injustice et tant de haine
aveugle face au terrorisme à
l'obscurantisme et à l'ignorance la
communauté éducative a d'ailleurs salué
la clarté des annonces de l'hommage en
ces différents temps et des mesures de
sécurité que vous avez prise rapidement
et communiquer directement après auprès
de ceci l'école et doit rester un
sanctuaire qui permet à chaque élève de
devenir un citoyen libre éclairé doté
des mêmes droits et devoirs et conscient
de faire partie d'une même société c'est
d'ailleurs le chemin que nous avons tous
suivi ici à ce titre nous sommes
nombreux à appeler de no vux un
renforcement significatif de l'éducation
morale et civique qui peut ne pas être
le seul objet voir parfois le seul poids
des professeurs d'histoire et de
géographie il doit pouvoir être amplifié
sanctuarisé approfondi et évalué avec de
nombreuses interventions extérieures
l'école ne doit en aucun cas
s'autocensurer au contraire elle est là
pour faire des républicains des citoyens
complets plus que jamais les professeurs
doivent avoir les moyens d'enseigner et
ce sont ces moyens que la mission que
vous présentez aujourd'hui apporte en
effet votre budget connaîtra en 2024 la
plus grande et plus importante
progression de tous les budgets de
l'État le portant à 63,6 milliards
d'euros près de 4 milliards d'euros de
plus qu'en 2023 les objectifs de ce
budget sont clairs et nos rapporteurs
Christophe Marion et Philippe F les ont
ont très bien expliqué dans un premier
temps et c'est historique mieux
rémunérer nos enseignants cette
augmentation concerne tous nos
professeurs elle est composée d'une
partie sans aucune condition à laquelle
peut s'additionner ensuite des
revalorisations liées à des missions
nouvelles ensuite améliorer l'accueil de
tous les élèves quel que soit leur
niveau ou leur situation personnelle à
ce titre le groupe renaissant se réjouit
de l'application de son amendement
visant à augmenter les aesh ainsi que
leur passage en CDI c'est un métier
essentiel pour une école inclusive et
nous souhaitons continuer les travaux
afin de pouvoir proposer à toutes celles
qui le souhait un emploi à temps complet
enfin en cohérence avec la
revalorisation des emplois ce budget
vient améliorer le taux d'encadrement et
ainsi poursuivre le dédoublement des
classes déjà bien engagées partout sur
notre territoire national je n'oublie
pas non plus la réforme des lycées
professionnels porté par la ministre
Carole grandangjan ni l'enjeu majeur que
qui se pose devant nos collectivités
territoriales quant à la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments scolaires chers
collègues ce budget traduit l'ambition
nouvelle que le Président de la
République et la majorité présidentielle
souhaitent porter pour notre école
monsieur le ministre vous avez fait des
annonces fortes lors de la rentrée
scolaire vous avez vous êtes emparé des
sujets de fond à commencer par les
programmes et l'affirmation des savoirs
fondamentaux tels que la lecture et les
mathématiques nous avons salué votre
annonce quant à la création d'une
commission exigence des savoirs et
souhaitons aujourd'hui connaître vos
pistes pour réhausser significativement
et durablement le niveau de nos écoliers
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député pour le rassemblement national
Roger chudau et je j'indique que je
suspendrai la séance ensuite merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre notre solidarité vis-à-vis de
Dominique Bernard de sa famille de ses
proches de ses collègues et de
l'éducation nationale est totale c'est
l'islamisme terroriste qui a armé le
bras de l'assassin mais il existe au
sein de notre école et vous le savez
très bien nous le savons tous un
islamisme rampant vous avez noté à
plusieurs reprises récemment que 50 %
des professeurs avaient décidé avait
pardon déclaré s'être
autocensuré cette situation n'est pas
nouvelle j'ai l'occasion de vous le dire
elle date au moins de 2004 c'est-à-dire
du rapport au bain et il faut dire que
les politiques qui sont succédés depuis
n'ont rien entrepris pour y remédier et
surtout ne me dites pas que ce sont les
haut fonctionnaires qui qui ortte la
responsabilité je vous en prie donc la
question que je vais vous poser c'est
avez-vous l'intention d'entreprendre
quelque chose d'assez sérieux et de
frontal pour mettre fin à l'islamisme
rampant s'en prend au fonctionnement
même de notre école et aux enseignements
qui sont dispensés venons-en maintenant
au budget 3 milliards 3,9 milliards
d'augmentation du budget 29 %
d'augmentation en 7 ans est-ce un effort
significatif la réponse est oui cette
part de la richesse nationale a-t-elle
et peut-elle produire des résultats en
matière d'amélioration de l'action
éducatrice de l'État ici la réponse est
clairement non l'essentiel de
l'augmentation des crédits est affecté à
la revalorisation des traitements des
enseignants fort bien mais cette
revalorisation passe à côté de
l'essentiel elle est indemnitaire et non
pas indiciaire pour une grande part en
tout cas et elle est assortie d'un Pact
qui ne mérite pas son nom et qui
d'ailleurs ne fonctionne ni pour le
remplacement ni pour le soutien scolaire
et je ne parle pas de l'effet de
l'inflation sur l'augmentation des
traitements ce budget est à nos yeux un
dispendieux budget de gestion c'est un
tonneau des danaïd tout l'inverse d'un
budget de mission stratégique tenant
compte de l'état réel du système
éducatif et du nécessaire sursaut
attendu par le pays prenons un exemple
la commission qui a l'honneur de vous
recevoir aujourd'hui a adopté un rapport
sur le bilan de l'éducation prioritaire
madame Caral était rapporteur j'en était
le président qui recommande notamment de
créer un programme distinct au sein de
la mission enseignement scolaire ceci
afin de pouvoir piloter une politique
publique qui concerne 20 % des élèves et
qui représente 8 milliards d'argent
public et surtout de permettre aussi un
contrôle parlementaire et bien nous ne
trouvons aucune trace de l'éducation
prioritaire dans ce budget si l'on
accepte la poursuite des dédoublements
ce qui est très bien enfin il s'agit
bien d'un budget de routine en
l'occurrence autre exemple le coût moyen
d'un écolier est à peu près de 6980 €
celui d'un lycéen de 9850 € c'est-à-dire
que la différence entre le 140 le
programme 140 et 141 est resté inchangé
depuis des décennies les pays qui ont de
bons résultat et bien on ont décidé de
mettre la priorité budgétaire sur le
premier degré ça n'est pas le cas
parlons enfin des emplois vous supprimez
en tout 2693 emplois de professeurs dans
les programmes 140 141 139 dans le
premier degré vous aurez donc en 2 ans
supprimer 2300 emplois on voit ici ce
qu'il faut penser de votre priorité aux
fondamentaux nous aurons je l'espère
bientôt l'occasion de débattre de ce
budget 2024 si le 493 nous en donne
l'occasion qui à nos yeux est surtout un
support rêvé pour une politique de
l'annonce une politique de plateau de
télévision très éloigné de l'impératif
catégorique de redressement de notre
système éducatif je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député donc je suspends la
séance et on se retrouve dans quelques
instantsons reprendre la
séance et donc nous sommes à nouveau en
direct et je vous propose que pour les
conversations privées vous les fassiez
vraiment à voix très très basse pour que
nous puissions entendre les orateurs et
donc je vais donner la parole à Paul
Vanier pour 4
minutes monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale l'attaque
terroriste de la cité scolaire Gambetta
à haras a coûté la vie à Dominique
Bernard professeur de lettre elle a
blessé un de ses collègues enseignants
et deux agents territoriaux dont un très
grièvement 3 ans après la mort de Samuel
paatti l'ensemble des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale le pays dans son
entier sont terriblement affectés par ce
nouvel assassinat d'un professeur tué
parce qu'il était professeur qu'est-ce
qu'être un professeur c'est élev de
jeunes esprits en formation à la liberté
et à l'autonomie de la pensée par le
savoir la raison et la culture Dominique
Bernard nous a montré jusqu'où pouvait
conduire cet engagement jusqu'à mettre
littéralement sa vie en jeu pour
protéger ses élèves à cet instant son
héroïsme celui de ses collègues
enseignants
personnels administratifs agents
techniques nous bouleverse toutes et
tous au-delà de l'émotion il fait sens
et nous
questionne nos gouvernements sont-ils à
la hauteur de cet engagement nos
gouvernements sont-ils à la hauteur de
nos professeurs nos gouvernements
sont-ils à la hauteur des besoins de nos
enfants non ils ne le sont pas ils ne le
sont plus depuis longtemps déjà à coup
de budget rabauté de postes supprimés de
salairire non revalorisés l'école
publique a été affaibli par une
succession de choix politiqu le métier
de professeur est entré dans une crise
que révèle à peine les milliers de
postes laissés vacants chaque année au
concours de l'éducation nationale des
dizaines de milliers d'élèves sont
abandonnés sans professeurs à la rentré
sans professeurs les jours suivants les
job dating sont devenus la règle les
inégalités scolaires s'approfondissent
en Guyane 10000 jeunes seraient privés
d'accès à l'école de la République
tandis que près de 3000 enfants
scolarisés dans l'Hexagone vivent dans
la
rue comme beaucoup d'autres avant lui ce
budget 2024 signe la forfaiture de nos
gouvernements vis-à-vis de l'école il
est la terrible illustration du fait que
passer le temps de l'émotion et de
l'hommage le soutien à nos professeurs
le souci de nos élèves et de leurs
familles ne se pai que de mots ce budget
2024 c'est 1709 postes supprimés dans le
1er degré 484 postes supprimés dans le 2
degré c'est le démantèlement du lycée
professionnel c'est la priorité donnée à
l'école privée dont le budget augmente
plus vite que celui de l'école publique
c'est la poursuite de la politique
d'appauvrissement des professeurs la
revalorisation historique affichée
accompagne en réalité une nouvelle perte
de pouvoir d'achat des enseignants eux
dont le salaire d'entrée dans la
carrière est passé de 2,2 SMIC dans les
années 80 à 1,26 SMIC cette année cet
effondrement doit être arrêté sinon
c'est toute la République qui peut être
emportée et pour cela monsieur le
ministre vous devez accepter la
nécessité d'un débat démocratique sur
l'école votre contre-réforme du lycée
professionnel a été imposée sans vote ni
débat les représentants des
organisations syndicales représentatives
des enseignants ont été méprisés
insultés ici même trois semaines avant
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard par
des députés de l'extrême droite et de
votre majorité c'est vrai votre
précédent budget a été imposé par 493 il
en sera de même pour celui-là c'est une
impasse monsieur le ministre une impasse
pas simplement pour vous mais une
impasse pour l'école de la
République merci pour les républicains
Annie jeunevard et Alexandre portier 2
minutes
chacun merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre gouverner c'est
choisir ses combats c'est établir des
priorités depuis l'assassinat par un
islamiste du professeur Dominique
Bernard la priorité à la sécurité de nos
établissements scolair s'impose et le
défi est immense on peut mettre en œuvre
tous les dispositifs technologiques et
humains le problème se réglera ailleurs
et notamment par la politique migratoire
que les républicains défendent ou du
moins son évolution et que les récents
et tragiques événements éclairent d'un
jour nouveau monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire ce que vous
entendez faire à l'égard des
contestataire de la minute de silence
vous avez décidé de mettre l'accent sur
un choc des savoirs en français et en
mathématiques à l'image du choc PISA en
Allemagne nous le réclamions depuis
longtemps accusé par nos opposants en
son temps qui voyait un SMIC éducatif le
niveau de nos élèves parfois celui de
professeurs recrutés à la hâte et sans
formation adéquate ont relégué cette
posture idéologique terriblement erronné
qui explique les piètres résultats de
nos élèves dans ses savoirs essentiels
vous avez annoncé la création d'une
mission consacrée à l'exigence des
savoirs fondamentaux et confié à des
professionnels qui doit rendre ses ses
conclusions dans 8 semaines les
premières mesures étant annoncées pour
la rentrée 2024 pouvez-vous nous en dire
quelques mots notre commission s'est
elle aussi emparé du sujet sur la
question de l'apprentissage de la
lecture apprentissage fondateur de tous
les autres entre 25 et 40 % selon
lesétablissements de nos élèves arrivent
en 6e en ne maîtrisant pas une lecture
fluide la massification question de la
scolarisation et la part grandissante
des d'élèves halophones n'explique pas
tout et en tout cas ne justifie en rien
l'impuissance de notre école
républicaine à donneré les mêmes chances
à tous si nous respectons parfaitement
le travail des experts nous les
auditionnons aussi prendrez-vous en
compte monsieur le ministre les
conclusions de cette mission que Fabrice
le vigoureux et moi menons et dont nous
envisageons de rendre les conclusions le
plus rapidement possible nous les
voulons utiles et opérationnell merci
madame la députée Alexandre
portier merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre nous sommes là pour
débattre du budget alors ce débat comme
vous le savez nous en avions été privés
l'an passé à cause du 493 d'où ma
première question aurons-nous le droit
cette année de débattre dans l'hémicycle
ou fuirez-vous vous aussi cette heure de
vérité devant les Français notre école
aujourd'hui n'est même plus capable de
protéger ni ses enseignants ni nos
enfants je ne parle pas du fait que
chaque semaine un agent de votre
ministère ce su décide ni du harcèlement
scolaire qui touche plus de 10 % de nos
enfants je parle tout simplement de la
sécurité la plus élémentaire à laquelle
n'ont eu droit ni Samuel paatti ni
Dominique Bernard dans le beaujolet dans
ma circonscription la semaine dernière
nous avons eu deux alertes à la bombe
dans des lycées et hier encore lundi une
jeune s'est rendue dans son collège avec
dans son sac un marteau et un cutter
notre école est chaque jour sous
pression et votre premier devoir
monsieur le ministre c'est évidemment la
sécurité de ceux que nous accueillons à
l'école qu'il soi enfant ou qu'il soi
adultes or dans ce budjet il n'y a rien
ce qui est incompréhensible pourtant les
solutions existent dans notre région
tous les lycées par exemple ont été
équipés de porti de sécurité dans ma
ville la ville franchorceau nous avons
doté toutes les écoles de 260 boîtiers
d'alerte mobile ce silence sur les
questions de sécurité n'a pour égal que
votre silence sur le lycée professionnel
il reste le parent pauvre de notre
système éducatif alors qu'il devrait en
être la voie royale aujourd'hui c'est la
première fois qu'on vous entend sur le
sujet et je suis désolé mais payer des
stages ce n'est pas un projet pour notre
école ce n'est pas un projet pour les
600000 lycéens qui compent le lycée
professionnel et enfin Monsieur le
Ministre pourquoi ne faites-vous pas de
l'égalité des chances le moteur de notre
école pas dans des discours mais dans
des actes en mettant en place une vraie
politique de bourse mérite digne de ce
nom et qui récompense enfin les élèves
les plus méritants je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour les
démocrates Laurent
Croisier merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues le
groupe démocrate tient à R hommage aux
professeurs Dominique Bernard et Samuel
Patti tous deux lâchement assassinés par
la folie meurtrière du terrorisme
islamiste nous souhaitons adresser à
leurs famillees à leurs collègues à
l'ensemble des enseignants et du
personnel de l'éducation nationale aux
élèves nos sincères
condoléances l'école est un pilier de la
République elle est un rempart elle
s'est construite autour de valeurs
fortes l'idéal républicain la promesse
d'émancipation le combat contre
l'assignation sociale et la lutte contre
les inégalités les professeurs en ont
toujours été les gardiens ces valeurs ne
sont pas négociables elles ne le seront
jamais le groupe démocrate souhaite des
établissements scolaire protecteur
sanctuaire où le harcèlement l'exclusion
le racisme le prosélitisme religieux n'y
ont pas leur place nous souhaitons une
école qui soit ce lieu de transmission
des savoir qui permet à tous les élèves
quel que soit leur milieu social de
s'émanciper et de construire un avenir
solide cette école parce que nous la
voulons bienveillante nous la devons
exigeante élever le niveau de l'école
nécessite de bonnes conditions
d'apprentissage pour les 12 millions
d'élèves de la maternelle au lycée ainsi
que des professeurs bien formés dont la
mission fondamentale reste la
transmission des savoirs et et des
compétences le groupe démocrate se
réjouit qu'avec plus de 64 milliards
d'euros le budget du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
soit le premier budget de l'État et
bénéficie d'une hausse historique de
près de 4 milliards d'euros depuis 2017
alors que la démographie scolaire est en
baisse le budget a augmenté de 30 % ce
qui démontre l'ambition forte de la
majorité présidentielle envers la
réussite des jeunes générations
le budget 2024 permet de mettre en œuvre
plusieurs priorités qui nous sont chères
parce que l'école est le lieu où se joue
la justice sociale nous nous réjouissons
que l'une des priorités de l'action
gouvernementale porte sur l'accueil des
enfants en situation de handicap le
projet de loi de finance 2024 prévoit
des moyens renforcés de 700 millions
d'euros par rapport à 2023 avec par
exemple 4800 postes supplémentaire
d'accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap depuis 2017 leur nombre ainsiug
augmenté de plus de 63 % et entre juin
2023 et janvier 2024 leur rémunération
progressera en moyenne de 13 % nous
souhaitons saluer les crédits consacrés
à la réforme du lycée professionnel 1
milliard d'euros sera investi en 2024
pour soutenir la réforme la voie
professionnelle doit impérativement
redevenir une voie de réussite une voie
d'excellence reconnue par tous enfin je
terminerai mon propos en parlant des
enseignants le groupe démocrate est
convaincu qu'il faut remettre les
professeurs au cœur du système éducatif
l'éducation nationale peine à recruter
il nous paraît important de recréer la
confiance l'envie d'être professeur et
de restaurer leur autorité dans la
société cela nécessite que les
enseignants soient légitimement reconnus
pour leur savoir et pour leurs
compétences à transmettre restaurer
l'attractivité du métier ne peut se
faire sans perspective de carrière
qualification égale les enseignants sont
moins payés que les autres
fonctionnaires de catégorie A à ce titre
la revalorisation salariale engagée
était indispensable et les moyens sont
inédits nous saluons ainsi pleinement le
renforcement de la revalorisation des
enseignants pour un montant total de 2,2
milliards d'euros cette revalorisation
devra se poursuivre pourquoi pas dans le
cadre d'une planification pluriannuelle
pourriez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
indiquer où en sont V réflexion à ce
sujet merci monsieur le député pour les
socialistes apparentés FA i merci merci
madame la Présidente j'aimerais tout
d'abord souligner comme combien il est
difficile de parler d'un projet de loi
de finances lorsque l'on est en
deuil c'est le deuil c'est un deuil
national c'est le deuil de l'école et je
m'associe à mes collègues pour rendre un
hommage appuyé à Dominique Bernard qui
est mon collègue et euh qui est euh pour
pour moi en tout cas euh le symbole de
de l'héroïsme des enseignants au
quotidien toutefois il faut parler du
projet de loi de finance et celui-ci
celui de 2024 nous inquiète et nous
inquiète sur trois points premièrement
l'État ne doit pas faire d'économie sur
le dos des professeurs en actant la
suppression de 2700 postes cette année
le gouvernement cautionne les classes
surchargé qui nuisent à la fois aux
apprentissages des élèves et aux
conditions de travail des enseignants la
baisse démographique pardon ne doit pas
être utilisée comme argument de statu
quo d'une situation qui n'est pas
satisfaisante au contraire elle doit
être le moteur à la baisse progressive
du nombre d'élèves par classe par
ailleurs il n'est pas entendable de
promettre un enseignant devant chaque
élève depuis biintôt 1 an et en même
temps de supprimer tant de postes qui
s'ajoute à la réduction déjà massive de
l'année dernière puisque l'année
dernière nous avions déjà 2000 postes
supprimés
en 2 ans cela fait
4700 postes de professeurs en Mo en
moins monsieur le ministre depuis que
qu'Emmanuel Macron est président de la
République c'est plus de 10000 postes en
moins second point d'inquiétude ce
projet de de finan ne prévoit aucun
poste supplémentaire aucun de personnel
socioéducatif pardon
médicosocial alors même que les manques
sont criants le défi autour de l'élève
aujourd'hui sont connu et partagé de
tous lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire lutte contre le décrochage
détection des signes de trouble lié à la
santé mentale de l'élève ainsi qu'aux
violences psychologique et physique dont
il peut être victime en dehors de
l'école pour cela l'élève doit être
mieux accompagné cela passe
indéiablement par plus d'assistant
social plus d'infirmiers scolaires de
médecins de psychologues de l'éducation
nationale pour que l'élève puisse se
tourner vers un professionnel de l'école
et que l'enseignant revienne à sa
mission première la transmission des
savoirs dans le second degré pour que
l'école parvienne àes à ses objectifs il
faut aussi que l'élève soi mieux encadré
et c'est le rôle des CPE et des
assistants d'éducation qui doivent être
plus nombreux ce qui n'est pas du tout
prévu dans la loi de
finances trème point d'inquiétude la
transformation des pial pôle d'inclusion
d'accompagnement enfin pardon pôle
inclusif d'accompagnement localisé en
passe pôle d'appui à la scolarité nous
sommes nous sommes et nous restons
opposés au pial depuis la création sous
le précédent quinquena si nous pensions
initialement qu'il s'agissait d'un un
simple changement de nom et qui n'aurait
rien réglé aux difficultés il semble que
le Pass ce pôle d'appui à la scolarité
aggrave la situation il est précisé dans
le projet do de finance que ce Pass sera
chargé de je cite définir la quotité
horaire de l'accompagnement individuel
que signifie cette mesure monsieur le
ministre la MDPH composée de personnel
médicaux qualifié ça normalement
s'occupe de décider de l'accompagnement
nécessaire pour les élèves en situation
de handicap quelle est la légitimité
donc de ce nouveau pass quels seront le
rôle et quel sera le rôle et le
périmètre d'action
en matière de notification de la MDPH
avec ces nouvelles missions du Pass nous
ne pouvons nous empêcher de penser que
cette nouvelle façon de faire permettra
à l'éducation nationale de recouvrir
plus de notifications en façade sans
augmenter le nombre de personnels
cachant ainsi les difficultés à recruter
les aesh en raison d'un métier aux
conditions d'exercice très peu
attractive pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté une autre école est possible
capable de relever les défis qu' l'
attendent pour le bien de nos élèves
madame la députée vous avez largement
dépassé de plus de 30 secondes je finis
juste ma phrase si c'est possible non et
ben tant pis pour moi alors merci donc
pour horizon et apparenté agnè
Carel merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre j'ai été
particulièrement attentive à votre
exposé sur le budget 2024 même si je
n'étais pas là mais je vous ai écouté je
ne peux donc que me réjouir comme mon
group mais et apparenté de la nouvelle
hausse importante de 3,9 milliards
d'euros du budget de l'Éducation
nationale vous connaissez mon
attachement à l'éducation nationale d'un
côté ou de l'autre du bureau depuis l'an
dernier ce budget augmente de manière
importante une priorité a été donné à la
revalorisation des salaires des
enseignants et du personnel à ces
revalorisations s'est ajouté la mise en
place du PACT enseignant qui dans ce
budget représente une enveloppe de 900
millions d'euros l'ensemble des
personnels enseignants CPE et si en
qu'il soit fonctionnaire ou contractuel
en fonction des besoins et sur la base
du volontariat peuvent euh peut pardon
assurer des missions complémentaires ce
pacte permet notamment de faciliter les
remplacements de courte de courte durée
mais aussi la mise en place de leur
hebdomadaire de soutien ou
d'approfondissement en français et
mathématique en 6e ou de participer au
dispositif devoirfit l'objectif de ces
missions est de participer à la réussite
des élèves et doit permettre de mettre
l'accent sur l'égalité des chances mais
depuis quelques mois les remontées de
terrain que j'ai sur dans ma
circonscription lorsque je vais à la
rencontre des enseignants des principaux
d'établissement ne sont pas
satisfaisantes loin sans faut en premier
lieu il semblerait que les décrets a
tardés à sortir et que les explication
reçu par les uns et les autres diffèrent
manque parfois de clarté et
d'explication par ailleurs le pacte
enseignant se met parfois en concurrence
avec les
HSE et il devient difficile pour nos
principaux de collège d'qu br les
dotations hires globales je ne parle pas
dans tout ça du climat compliqué que
cela a engendré dans certaines salles de
professeurs quelle mesure comptez-vous
prendre pour revoir la communication sur
ce Pact enseignant dont je suis
convaincu de la de la la légitimité afin
qu'il soit mieux compris mieux intégré
et surtout mieux accepté par les
enseignants en règle générale merci
merci madame la députée pour les
écologistes Francesca pascini merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre le contexte de l'examen des
budgets de la mission enseignement
scolaire est particulièrement difficile
cette année du fait du terrible
assassinat de Dominique Bernard cet
événement tragique nous rappelle combien
l'engagement pour l'école de la
République et ses élèves doit être
indéfectible et inébranlable nous le
devons à tous au personnels aux enfants
et à leurs familles monsieur le ministre
l'an dernier le 493 et les manœuvres du
gouvernement ont privé l'Assemblée
nationale d'un vrai débat sur l'école en
séance publique il serait scandaleux que
les députés de la nation ne puissent pas
débattre un seul instant du premier
budget de l'État dans l'hémicycle aussi
je souhaite commencer cette intervention
par une question pouvez-vous nous
confirmer que vous défendrez ce budget
en séance avant le 493 si vous ne le
faites pas monsieur le ministre vous
savez vous perdrez de la crédibilité à
nos yeux j'en viens au fond de ce budget
2024 pour vous partager notre vive
inquiétude suivez cette année la
suppression de postes d'enseignant
contre toute logique et contre l'intérêt
des élèves 2500 postes vont disparaître
en 2024 malgré les alertes des syndicats
et les classes surchargées vous affichez
l'objectif d'améliorer les taux
d'encadrement dans le premier comme dans
le second degré mais manquz de passer
des mots aux actes ce budget n'est pas
non plus au rendez-vous de
l'augmentation inconditionnel de 10 %
pour tous les enseignants le milliard
d'euros que vous allouez au Pact aurait
pourtant pu permettre de financer cette
hausse les écologistes défendront donc
le réhaussement du nombre de professeurs
et la hausse de leur rémunération dans
l'intérêt de nos enfants et de la
communauté éducative ces deux mesures
sont nécessaires pour que la promesse du
président de la République d'avoir un
professeur devant chaque classe se
réalise nous espérons que vous entendrez
raison j'en termine par une remarque sur
la crise du système de médecine scolaire
face au défi de l'école du harcèlement
des violences faites aux enfants ce
système a besoin d'un électronchoc de
nombreux amendements vont dans ce sens
j'espère que vous les soutiendrez que
vous soutiendrez les avancer en la
matière enfin monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez dit on ne peut pas accepter que
dans l'école de la République on est
trop froid l'hiver et trop chaud l'été
la rénovation des bâtiments scolaires
est une mesure essentielle pour le
bien-être des élèves et des personnels
de l'éducation national bien que ces
budgets ne soient pas inscrits dans la
mission enseignement scolaire le groupe
écologiste F ite que le gouvernement
prenne enfin la mesure de l'enjeu
néanmoins vous le savez en qualité
d'ancien ministre des comptes publies la
les collectivités territorial sont face
à un mur d'investissement pour réussir
la transition écologique le demi
mililliard d'euros débloqué nous semble
donc insuffisant et nous nous appelons à
de plus grandes ambitions en la matière
ce n'est qu'avec un grand plan
d'investissement pluriannuel dans les
bâtiments du 1er et du second degré que
nous pourrons garantir aux des bonnes
conditions d'apprentissage je vous en
remercie merci madame la députée pour le
groupe GDR Frédéric
maillot je m'appelle Moussa j'ai 10 ans
je suis en CM2 à épiné ville de 93 où
j'ai grandi où je suis né mon école est
mignonne même si les murs sont pas tout
neufs dans chaque place il y a plein de
bruit moi dans ma classe on est 29 il y
a beaucoup d'élèves modèles et puis on
est un peu dissipé je crois ce qu' nous
sommes ce qu'on appelle des élèves en
difficulté moi en mat je suis pas
terrible mais c'est papier qu' dicté je
préfère 16es heures où je retrouve les
grands de ma cité pourtant ma maîtresse
je l'aime bien elle est peut-être un peu
dure mais elle est patiante si je
comprends pas elle me réexplique elle
est patiante elle a toujours plein
d'idées et des projets pour les sorties
mais on a que deux quart par an prêté
par la mairie je crois qu' mon école
elle est pauvre on n' pas de ça à
l'informatique on a que la cour et le
préo pour faire de la gymnastique à la
télé j'ai vu que des classes faisaient
du golf en EPS nous on a que des tapis
et des cerceaux et la détresse de nos
maîtresses alors si tout se joue à
l'école il est temps d'entendre le ses
ne laissez pas creuser le fossé de
l'enseignement à deux vitesses au milieu
des tours il y a trop de de pion dans le
jeu d'échecs scolaire ne laissons pas
nos rois devenir fous dans les desfites
spectaculaires l'enseignement en France
va mal personne peut le nier les zones
d'éducation prioritaires ne sont pas des
priorités les classes sont surchargées
pas comme la paye des profs minés et on
supprime des effectifs dans les écoles
déjà en apné au contraire il faut
ajouter des profs et d'autres métiers
qui prennent la relève dans les
quartiers les plus en galère créer des
classes de 15 élèves ajouter des postes
d'assistance ou d'auxiliaire qui aident
au devoir qui connaissent les parents et
accompagnent les enfants les plus en
retard l'enseignement en France va mal
l'État ne met pas assez d'argent
quelques réformes à de balles pour ne
pas voir le plus urgent un établissement
scolaire sans vrais moyens est
impuissant comment peut-on faire des
économies sur l'avenir de nos enfants
l'enseignement en France va mal car il
ne rend pas les gens égaux les plus
fragiles tirent l'alarme mais on étouffe
leur écho l'école public va mal car a la
tête sous l'eau il n'y a pas d'éducation
nationale il y a que des moyens de
survie locaux alors continuons de dire à
nos petits frères que l'école est la
solution mais donnons-leur les bons
outils pour leur avenir car attention la
récite scolaire dans certaines zones
pourrait rester un mystère et les
qualités des chances un concept de
ministère alors si tout se joue à
l'école il est temps d'entendre le ses
ne laissons pas creuser le fossé d'un
enseignement à deux vitesse au milieu
des tours il y a trop de pions dans le
jeu d'échecs scolaire ne laissons pas
nos rois devenir fous dans des défaites
spectaculaires je m'appelle Moussa j'ai
10 ans je suis en CM2 à épinet ville de
93 où j'ai grandi où je suis né c'est
pas de ma faute à moi si j'ai moins de
chances d'avoir le bac c'est simplement
parce que là où je vis que mon avenir
est dans un cul de sac monsieur le
ministre ces mots ne sont pas de moi
mais mes collègues l'auront compris ni
cell de mon collague ni celle même de
chat GPT mais c'est un cor un texte de
Grand Corps Malade qui a exprimer tout
l'importance de l'éducation et ça aurait
pu être l'histoire de Moussa c'est
l'histoire de Jérémie de la Réunion
deémilie en Martinique ou de Sébastien
en guyan mais simplement pour vous dire
que ne laissez pas le 493 nous priver de
débat sur le budget le plus important
pas seulement en chiffre mais sur
l'avenir du pays ne laissez pas le 493
nous priver du débat sur l'avenir de nos
enfants merci merci monsieur le député
pour le groupe lot Béatrice
Descamp merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègue je tiens moi
aussi à faire part de la solidarité de
mon groupe au proche de Dominique
Bernard assassiné par ce qu'enseignant
décédé d'avoir voulu protéger ses élèves
solidarité aussi à toute la communauté
éducative dont je considère faire partie
encore 3 ans après l'assassinat de
Samuel paatti les enseignants se
retrouvent une nouvelle fois la cible du
terrorisme islamiste les mots manquent
face à l'horreur à l'émotion que nous
éprouvons notre soutien envers l'école
ses acteurs doit être
total c'est dans cet esprit dans cette
exigence que notre groupe a abordé les
crédits de la mission enseignement
scolaire ils sont en hos et contiennent
des avancées que nous saluons il
demeurent toutefois quelques ombres au
tableau s'expliquant par le manque de
volonté en matière d'éducation pendant
trop
d'années d'abord sur la question des
revalorisations des enseignants celles
des néotitulaires successives ces
derniers mois ont permis un premier
rattrapage néanmoins beaucoup de retards
ont été pris je le répète ces 15
dernières années par conséquent nous
craignons que les revalorisations ne
permettent pas de rendre le métier
attractif surtout en cette période
d'inflation quant au Pact enseignant il
peine à faire écho près des enseignants
aussi notre groupe appelle à la mise en
place d'un plan de revalorisation
pluriannuel pour offrir des perspectives
à nos enseignants notamment en milieu de
carrière par ailleurs notre groupe
regrette les diminutions
d'effectifs la diminution du nombre
d'élèves devrait selon nous être
l'opportunité de diminuer le nombre
d'élèves par
classe comme cela a fait ses preuves en
Rep et REP plus avec les plafonnements
et dédoublements des classes s'agissant
du soutien aux communes notre groupe
déplore la suppression du fond de
soutien au développement des activités
périscolaires c'est une atteinte
conséquente aux communes qui continuent
de mettre en œuvre ces activités et ce
sont les élèves qui en seront les
premiers pénalisé quand bien même
sont-ils peu nombreux ou moins nombreux
je tiens absolument à alerter cette
année encore je n'ai pas été très
entendu les années précédentes peut-être
cette année sur la question de la santé
à l'école et sur le manque de médecin
d'infirmiers scolaire qui a des
conséquences désastreuses pour beaucoup
d'enfants le médecin scolaire
l'infirmier sont les scolair sont les
seul professionnel de santé qu'il
consulte les questions de prévention de
maltraitance il y a le manque croissant
de médecins de famille l'accompagnement
des élèves atteints de pathologie
chronique ou de maladies graves
nécessite de prendre la mesure de la
gravité de la situation et de pouvoir à
pourvoir à nouveau les écoles de en
médecin et en infirmierers j'ai déposé
des amendements en ce sens même constat
pour les assistants sociaux et pour les
psychologues scolaires et tout
particulièrement pour ces derniers au vu
des situations de harcèlement scolaire
et à la détresse psychologique des des
jeunes des situations aux issus parfois
dramatiques malheureusement nous le
savons enfin je terminerai par la
scolarité des élèves en situation de
handicap même s'il reste à faire et
notamment dans l'efficacité des piales
passe j'entends sur le terrain que
certains fonctionnent bien que dans
d'autres circonscriptions c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué force est de constater
que les efforts ont été faits de la part
du gouvernement à destination des aesh
et il est important de saluer les
mesures qui vont dans le bon sens et
sont à poursuivre j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir sur d'autres propositions de
mesures pour favoriser encore
l'inclusion scolaire lors de l'examen
des amendements et j'espère pouvoir être
entendu sur ce sujet que je porte depuis
longtemps je vous remercie merci madame
la députée monsieur le ministre vous
allez avoir le la parole pour pouvoir
répondre oui déjà à à mes collègues et
ce que je vous propose c'est de faire
des réponses synthétique puisque nous
avons à nouveau 30 collègues qui vous
poseront à nouveau des questions et donc
vous aurez l'occasion à ce moment-là si
vous le souhaitez de revenir et
d'approfondir un certain nombre de
réponses de revenir sur les points que
vous n'aurez
oui mais après après après si vous
vousoulez mais tout à fait donc non non
c'était mes chers collègues le ministre
a la
parole merci Madame la prés présidente
merci aux députés qui se sont exprimés
et notamment aux deux rapporteurs
Christophe Marion Philippe fait qui sont
intervenus sur un certain nombre de
sujets évidemment majeurs pour notre
école notamment s'agissant du rôle de
l'école dans l'amélioration de la santé
et du bien-être des élèves d'autres
parmi vous sont intervenus sur ce sujet
notamment Béatrice descand il y a un
instant c'est c'est évidemment un enjeu
absolument majeur en majeur en matière
de prévention des conduites addictives
majeur en en matière d'éducation à
l'alimentation et au goût majeur en
matière de promotion de l'activité
physique de la santé mentale et du
bien-être et je crois que on peut tous
être préoccupé par la santé mentale le
bien-être psychologique de nos élèves en
matière de santé environnementale
également et tous vous êtes intervenu
sur le rôle de la médecine scolaire en
dans cette direction évidemment il est
majeur la difficulté vous le savez c'est
pas une question de nombre de postes
c'est une question de postes qui ne sont
pas pourvu je crois que c'est 40 5 % de
nos postes de médecins scolair qui ne
sont pas pourvus par manque
d'attractivité je suis pas certain même
si on a fait un certain nombre d'effort
sur le sujet et qu'on peut tout à fait
continuer à le faire il y a des
amendements qui sont proposés je pense
que c'est important qu'il soit débattu
ce soit uniquement une question de
rémunération en tout cas ce qu'on a
observer c'est quand les rémunérations
on étaient augmenté y compris encore
récemment quand on a ouvert l'accès au
prime REP et REP plus assez personnel ça
n'a pas eu d'impact majeur on sait que
sur les médecins il y a un enjeu global
de démographie médicale il manque des
médecins aussi en en ville il manque des
médecins aussi dans les établissements
de santé et médicau-sociaux et donc je
pense profondément que dans les années
qui viennent d'ici à ce que les
décisions que nous avons prises sur le
numérous closus produis un impact en
matière de nombre de médecins qui
arriveront sur le terrain c'est vraiment
par la coopération avec la ville avec
les établissements de santé qu'on
arrivera à avoir une plus grande
présence médicale s'agissant des postes
d'infirmière Scola là aussi je pense
qu'il faut continuer à s'interroger
toujours à regarder ce qu'on peut faire
en matière d'alignement de grille même
si là aussi ces dernières années on a
fait un certain nombre d'efforts a
massivement augmenté le budget alloué je
pense qu'il faut qu'on regarde aussi sur
les leviers qu'on peut donner à nos
infirmières scolaires qui souhaitent par
exemple pouvoir cumuler avec de
l'exercice libéral à côté je pense que
ça peut être un des enjeux
d'attractivité en tout cas sur le
terrain ça m'a été demandé par un
certain nombre d'infirmière dans des
établissements que j'ai pu rencontrer
Monsieur bataillon est revenu sur
plusieurs sujets notamment sur la
réforme de l'enseignement moral et
civique sur ce sujet-là pour vous
répondre vous le savez que mon
prédécesseur avait missionné le Conseil
super rieur des programmes j'attends ces
propositions pour la fin de l'année et
je souhaite pouvoir annoncer mes
décisions en début d'année après un
temps de concertation évidemment avec
les organisations syndicales mais aussi
un temps de travail avec les
parlementaires je sais que vous êtes
nombreux à vous être mobilisés sur ce
sujet-l je pense que ce qui doit guider
nos réflexions c'est à la fois le volume
horaire qu'on souhaite dédier à l'UMC la
manière dont on garantit que ce volume
horaire est effectivement
respecté et enfin les grandes
orientations les grandes missions qu'on
donne à à l'UMC je pense que beaucoup
ont pu se diluer ces dernières années à
mesure qu'on rajoutait qu' on chargeait
l' MC d'un certain nombre de mission de
priorités à la fin on peine à distinguer
quelles sont les priorités pour moi
elles sont claires l'école doit former
des républicains des citoyens éclairés
et une fois qu'on a fixé rappelé cet
objectif je pense qu'on peut décliner
assez facilement un certain nombre de
grandes orientations je rappelle que le
Président de la République souhaite
également qu'on puisse lire chaque
semaine dans nos établissements un texte
fondamental de notre République ça fera
aussi partie d'un travail qu'on devra
mener avec les historiens avec vous sur
la sélection des textes qui seront
proposés dans ce cadre monsieur chudo
vous êtes revenu sur plusieurs points je
veux revenir sur un point que vous avez
évoqué sur la question du nombre de
postes vous pouvez pas ne regarder que
la question du nombre de postes sans
regarder évidemment la question du
nombre d'élèves et la démographie
scolaire pour dire les choses clairement
ces dernières années du fait de la
démographie et je crois qu'on souhaite
tous en tout cas je l'espère améliorer
la natalité dans notre pays et les
derniers chiffres sont particulièrement
inquiétants malgré la démographie qui
nous a fait perdre 300000 élèves ces 5
dernières années nous avons créé
plusieurs milliers de postes là où si on
avait suivi stricto sensu la démographie
on aurait on aurait supprimé plusieurs
dizaines de milliers juste pour
maintenir le même taux d'encadrement
c'est pour ça qu'on a un taux
d'encadrement qui s'est amélioré qui est
passé d'un peu plus de 24 élèves par
classe dans le 1emier degré en 2017 à un
peu plus de 21 élèves par classe dans le
premier degré l'an prochain en
moyenne dans les années qui viennent
toutes les études montrent démographiqu
qu'on perdra plus de 400000 élèves
supplémentaires et pour être très
concret sur l'année prochaine on sait
qu'il y aura une baisse démographique à
nouveau aujourd'hui on a 860000
enseignants si on voulait garder le même
taux d'encadrement l'an prochain on
recruterait des enseignants pour passer
à 855000 enseignants pour garder le même
taux d'encadrement on va en recruter
suffisamment pour avoir 857500
enseignants l'an prochain donc on va
continuer à améliorer le taux
d'encadrement donc je pense que c'est
important de mettre cela en
euh perspective je reviendrai dans un
instant puisque d'autres l'ont évoqué
sur la question des comparaisons euh du
coûp d'élèves en primaire par rapport au
second degré puisque j'ai des nouveaux
chiffres à vous donner qui vont vous
intéresser mais je crois que d'autres il
sont revenus monsieur Vanier vous êtes
notamment revenu sur la question du LCÉE
professionnel je crois pas dire je crois
pas qu'on puisse dire que c'est une
réforme d'abandon du lycée professionnel
quand elle coûte 1 milliard d'euros
c'est pas une réforme d'économie c'est
une réforme d'investissement avec cette
réforme on va investir 1 milliard
d'euros supplémentaires par an pour le
Lycée professionnel et c'est pas du tout
uniquement la gratification des stages
monsieur portier même si je pense que
c'est important c'est une mesure de
justice pour des élèves qui sont en
stage en lycée pro par rapport à ceux
qui sont en apprentissage j'espère que
ça sera une mesure de persévérance
scolaire il faudra qu'on le regarde
l'objectif c'est évidemment que les
élèves aillent en stage mais aussi
qu'ils suivent les enseignements au
lycée et je pense qu'on on aura
l'occasion de de d'évaluer cela mais
cette réforme c'est beaucoup d'autres
choses c'est un renforcement des
fondamentaux c'est des options
supplémentaires qui sont données en
langue vivante en entreprene at en
numérique c'est des enseignements en
plus petit groupe sur les fondamentaux
pour maîtriser mieux la lecture
l'écriture et le calcul c'est un vrai
travail courageux je crois mené par ma
ministre délégué Carole grandangan sur
la carte des formations en assumant
qu'il y a un certain nombre de formation
dont on sait très bien qu'ell ne
permettent ensuite quasiment aucune
insertion dans l'emploi aucune poursuite
d'étude et qu'il faut assumer de fermer
un certain nombre de formations mais
pour en ouvrir d'autres dans des
secteurs qui recrutent et qui permettent
aussi une poursuite d'études on va mener
ce travail dans les semaines qui
viennent avec Carole Grandjean en lien
avec les acteurs
économiques
territoriaux bien évidemment je poursuis
ensuite pardon je peux reprendre la
liste c'était madame Genevard qui éta
intervenue et qui est intervenu sur un
certain nombre de sujets notamment sur
la question de l'élévation du niveau
général quand un bataillon est aussi
intervenu sur le sujet effectivement
j'ai annoncé lancé une mission exigence
des savoirs dans un contexte que chacun
connaît où nous avons eu ces dernières
décennies une baisse du niveau général
un élève de 2018 le 4e avait le niveau
d'un élève de 5e de 1995 ce qui veut
dire qu'en 23 ans on a perdu globalement
un an de niveau on a maintenant des
évaluations nationales qui sont
réalisées chaque année c'est l'apport
notamment de Jean-Michel Blanquer ça
nous donne une visibilité sur le niveau
de nos élèves on a un élève sur tro qui
rentre en 6e aujourd'hui sans maîtriser
convenablement la lecture l'écriture et
le calcul et on a un élève sur de en
classe de 6e qui ne sait pas dire
combien il y a de quart d'heure dans la
fraction 3 qu4 d'heure et en 3e au
moment du diplôme national du brevet 25
% des élèves ont moins de 4/ 20 à
l'épreuve de mathématique le 4 étant la
note la plus distribuée au brevet des
collèges en mathématiques personne ne
peut satisfaire de cette situation et je
le dis elle la responsabilité ni des
enseignants ni des élèves ni des
familles elle est de il est de notre
responsabilité de prendre les mesures
qui conviennent pour élever le niveau
général dans un pays où je le rappelle
nous sommes le pays de l'OCDE qui
consacre le plus de temps à ces
disciplines fondamental notamment en
primaire donc pas une question de durée
c'est une question de ce qui se passe
dans ces cours je l'ai dit le nombre
d'élèves par classe améliore les choses
on a vu une réduction des écarts entre
éducation prioritaire et les autres en
lecture en écriture et en calcul grâce à
à la réduction des effectifs mais on
peut faire beaucoup par ailleurs en
matière de formation des enseignants
d'où la réforme de la formation initiale
et je pense que j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir devant vous sur ce sujet qui est
absolument majeur d'où les plans de
formation continu le plan lecture le
plan mathématique qui nous permettent de
reformer tous les 6 ans l'ensemble des
professeurs des écoles sur la lecture
l'écriture les mathématiques d'où le
travail qu'on doit engager j'assume ce
travail même si je sais qu'il est
difficile et que je respecte la liberté
pédagogique des enseignants mais le
travail sur les manuels scolaires dans
un contexte où 60 % des élèves de cma1
n'ont pas de manuel de référence ce qui
conduit parfois des professeurs des
écoles des enseignants à aller chercher
des ressources qui ne sont pas toujours
les meilleures ressources prouvées
scientifiquement comme étant à même de
permettre à nos enfants d'apprendre à
lire écrire et compter ou parfois les
les manuels qui sont proposés aux élèves
ne sont pas des manuels qui proposent
des méthodes prouvées efficacement par
la science comme étant efficace sur ces
enjeux là donc oui j'assume de poser à
cette mission la question de la
labellisation de Manuel Scola dont on
sait qu' propose des méthodes qui sont
utiles à nos élèves de la même manière
que je pose la question alors qu'on a un
élève sur 3 qui rentre en 6e sans savoir
lire écrire et compter convenablement
est-ce qu'il faut continuer à leur
permettre de rentrer en 6e dans les
mêmes
conditions est-ce qu'il faut finalement
pas se poser la question de savoir si
l'intérêt de ses élèves c'est de passer
en 6e sans évidemment qu'on leur propose
de refaire exactement la même année
qu'ils ont connu en CM2 ou est-ce que à
ce moment-là c'est passé en 6e mais en
faisant la rentrée scolaire de semaines
avant les autres et en faisant des
stages de réussite pendant ces petites
vacances un élève qu'on laisse rentrer
en 6e dans ses conditions on sait
on lui donne toutes les chances de
décrocher dans les années qui suivent au
collège ou au lycée c'est pas un service
à lu rend donc il faut bien trouver une
autre organisation de la même manière
sur le collège beaucoup d'enseignants me
disent que le niveau est tellement
hétérogène notamment en français en
mathématique dans leur classe que oui
réfléchir à une organisation non pas en
classe de niveau mais en groupe de
compétences sur le français et les
mathématiques permettrait de faire
progresser tout le monde là où à la fin
on a parfois des organisations qui
finissent par tirer tout le monde vers
le bas je sais que c'est pas plus facile
que de faire ce constat et d'assumer de
dire ces chosesl mais en tout cas je les
assume et j'assume surtout de laisser
une mission travailler en lien avec les
organisations syndical des professeurs
du terrain je rappelle qu'il y en a dans
chaque chacun des groupes de travail de
cette mission on li avec des inspecteurs
avec des recteurs je souhaite qu'il
puisse qu'on puisse trouver une modalité
pour que cette mission puisse être
associée aux travaux de votre commission
pour vous puissiez aussi contribuer mais
c'est une mission qui est
particulièrement
importante monsieur portier vous étiez
revenu sur un certain nombre de sujets
j'ai j'ai répondu notamment sur la
réforme du lycée professionnel sur les
bourses au mérite il y a 150000 élèves
qui bénéficient d'une bourse au mérite
qui s'élève de 400 à 1000 € par an elle
est attribuée à tous les élèves
boursiers lauréat d'une mention bien ou
très bien au brevet des collèges et
aller verser jusqu'au baccalauréat ou
jusqu'au cap euh dans le cadre de la
mission exigence des savoir et poser
aussi la question du niveau d'exigence
sur le brevet des collèges donc je le
dis ici euh ça vaut pour le nombre
d'élèves qui ont le brevet et sur
évidemment la question des mentions vous
m'avez interrogé sur les alertes à la
bombe font l'objet nos établissement
scolair on en est depuis le 4 septembre
à 173 fausse alerte à la bombe envoyée à
nos établissements j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire hier c'est totalement
inadmissible et insupportable ça all est
d'autant plus dans le contexte qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui avec les angoisses
et les inquiétudes je rappelle qu'ier il
y a quand même eu une fausse alerte qui
a été faite au lycée d'Arras au moment
du temps d'ommage à Dominique Bernard
c'est juste
insupportable on travaille avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur pour identifier
à chaque fois les auteurs on en
identifie on a encore eu des
interpellations hier si personnes il y
en avait eu à la fin du mois de
septembre c'est souvent des mineurs
c'est souvent des mineurs qui ont un
lien avec l'établissement ça peut être
ce qu'on qualifie parfois de canular et
je le dis ça n'est pas du canular c'est
de la déstabilisation d'élèves et
d'équipes enseignantes et donc
évidemment et on le rappelle
régulièrement on souhaite que la justice
s'enare de ces dossiers avec une grande
fermeté une grande sévérité là aussi je
le dis il faut faire des exemples il
faut envoyer un message de grande
fermeté euh sur
ensuite monsieur Croisier je veux
rappeler qu'indépendamment des mesures
socle de revalorisation qui
interviennent en cette rentrée d'autres
mesures interviennent par ailleurs je ne
les classe pas dans la catégorie
revalorisation mais en cette rentrée on
passe par exemple la prise en charge de
l'abonnement transport par exemple en
Île-de-France le Pass navico de 50 % à
75 % par l'employeur donc c'est
concrètement aussi un remboursement en
plus pour les enseignants c'est une
mesure pour tous les fonctionnaires mais
je rappelle qu'on est l'administration
qui en a le plus donc voilà il y a la
prime pouvoir d'achat que j'évoqué tout
à l'heure une autre mesure qui va
bénéficier à tous les enseignants en
janvier 2024 c'est l'injection de 5
point d'indice majoré pour tous les
fonctionnaires là aussi ça va continuer
à améliorer ce qui me permet de vous
dire que si on cumule depuis la
réélection du président de la République
en avril 2022 les deux revalorisations
du point d'indice la revalorisation
socle de cette rentrée et les C points
d'indice majoré supplémentaire en
janvier ça fait en moyenne 11 % de
revalorisation pour nos enseignants
c'est évidemment beaucoup plus en début
de carrière c'est un peu moins en fin de
carrière on voit aujourd'hui qu'en
janvier on sera au-dessus de la moyenne
au CDE en matière de rémunération de nos
enseignant en début de carrière et en
fin de carrière reste un retard
important en milieu de carrière on sait
que c'est làù on doit continuer à
travailler il y a notamment aussi
parfois j'aime pas ce terme certains
médias parlent de coup de blouse de
milieu de carrière en tout cas de doute
sur sa arrière en milieu de carrière il
y a un creux dans le chantier
attractivité que j'ai ouvert avec les
enseignants on travaille notamment sur
cette question là en matière
d'avancement dans la carrière pour les
milieux de carrière plusieurs vous êtes
intervenus cétait le cas de Monsieur
chudo je le disais et d'autres sur la
question des de nos dépenses par élèv
dans le premier degré en 2017 quand le
président de la République a été élu on
dépensait 6900 € par élève dans le prer
degré je crois que c'est le chiffre que
vous avez avait évoqué monsieur chudau
après toutes les mesures que nous avons
mis en place depuis 2017 on est
maintenant à 7900 € par élève en dans le
premier degré on est encore en dessous
de la moyenne de l'OCDE mais en tout cas
on s'en rapproche et on n pas d'exemple
non plus dans les précédents quinena on
s'en est rapproché aussi vite et on
dépense c'est vrai toujours beaucoup
plus que la moyenne de l'OCDE dans le
second degré et en lycée professionnel
et c'est dans le 1emer degré on a du
retard et dans les seconds degrés on
dépense plus que la moyenne de de l'OCDE
mais encore une fois pour avoir été à
l'OCDE pour la remise de leur rapport
regard sur l'éducation ils le disent
tous le facteur clé pour l'élévation du
niveau c'est la formation des des
enseignants euh c'est le le facteur clé
les fait maître comme ils disent et donc
on doit continuer à concentrer nos
moyens sur ce sujet-là
euh madame kelochi je veux vraiment vous
répondre le nombre d'élèves par classe
n'augmente pas il baisse euh dans le
primaire je le redis nous passerons de
23,6 élèves par classe en 2017 à 21,4 en
2024 évidemment ça intègre les
dédoublements c'est une moyenne et je
rappelle qu'on plafonne aussi à 24
élèves par classe dans le reste des
établissements par ailleurs demander à
la mission exigence des savoirs de
mesurer si on constate déjà un effet de
cette mesure ou pas est-ce qu'on doit
continuer à concentrer sur certains
élèves ou avoir cette mesure générale je
pense que la boussole ça doit être
toujours l'élévation du niveau de nos
élèves vous dites qu'il y a eu 100
postes supprimés depuis 2017 c'est faux
si on prend le nombre de postes entre
2017 et 2022 il y a eu 2170 créations
nettes de poste de
professeur je fais la même réponse pour
Madame Pasquini qui m'a posé la question
sur les AED depuis 2017 hausse de 5500
du nombre d'AED on était à 62000 postes
d'AED en 2017 on sera l'an prochain à
67500 postes d'AED évidemment que la
question se pose de continuer à
renforcer les postes d'UD on en a besoin
pour lutter contre le harcèlement
scolaire on en a besoin par ailleurs
pour la sécurité dans nos établissements
scolaires et c'est l'équivalent de 10 %
de revalorisation et de renforcement de
ses effectifs je rappelle que depuis
2022 on a également créé 400 postes de
CPE là aussi important pour la vie
scolaire sur les passes je vais revenir
sur ce sujet là
franchement on souhaite tous qu'il ait
enfin maintenant après le saut
quantitatif un saut qualitatif dans la
des élèves en situation de handicap et
comme vous je suis frappé parfois de la
détresse que j'entends évidemment de
famille mais aussi de professeurs des
écoles qui se sentent parfois dépassés
par les difficultés qu'ils ont à
accueillir mais je le dis il faut qu'on
puisse expérimenter ces pôles d'appui à
la scolarité ses passes qui vont nous
permettre de mieux accueillir parce
qu'il permettront de faire intervenir
des professionnels du médicosocial
auprès des professeurs des écoles parce
qu'il vont permettre d'avoir un point
d'entrée unique pour les familles y
compris pour les accompagner dans le
leur démarche avec la MDPH parce qu'ils
vont nous permettre d'apporter une
réponse de premier niveau sans attendre
la réponse de la MDPH pour des élèves en
matière d'adaptation du matériel
pédagogique notamment donc expérimenter
les passes c'est se donner une chance
d'arriver à améliorer l'accueil euh d'un
point de vue qualitatif de nos élèves en
situation de handicap j'espère que cette
mesure sera soutenue euh madame Carel
vous êtes intervenu sur
plusieurs sujets notamment évidemment
sur la question éducation prioritaire
qui vous tient particulièrement à cœur
et vous avez évidemment commis un un
rapport très important sur ce sujet pour
lequel nous avons retenu un certain
nombre de mesures qui sont
particulièrement importantes oui on va
continuer à renforcer les moyens je le
disais à l'instant 60 ouverture de très
petites sections D 2 ans dans les
quartiers politiques de la ville
l'achèvement du dédoublement des classes
en grande section de maternelle le 8h
18h qu'on veut élargir dans les collèges
j'indique d'ailleurs que il y aura
beaucoup plus de collèges qui feront le
8h1h que ce qui était prévu cette année
parce qu'on a souhaité pousser vraiment
sur ce sujet-l donc on va évidemment
continuer madame Pasquini vous êtes
notamment revenu et je sais que vous
travaillez sur ce sujet là dans le cadre
d'une mission avec radiela Melkor sur le
l'isolation thermique de nos bâtiments
publics j'étais intervenu dans ma mon
propos liminire c'est un enjeu majeur
pour le bien-être des élèves des
enseignants et pour l'atteindre de nos
objectifs de la Stratégie nationale bac
carbone on veut rénover 40000 écoles
dans les 10 ans qui viennent ça veut
dire qu'on multiplie par TR ou qu le rit
de rénovation annuelle dans notre pays
et comme c'est de la compétence des
collectivités locales normalement l'état
au-delà de dcil desetr ne met pas de
crédit mais première fois on met des
crédits 500 millions d'euros par an dans
le fond vert c'est inédit en plus de ce
que fait la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation donc ça c'est c'est c'est
un investissement massif pour atteindre
ses
objectifs madame pardon monsieur maillot
merci pour
votre
témoignage euh je reviens pas sur tout
ce que j'ai dit sur le renforcement des
moyens en éducation prioritaire encore
une fois on peut faire toujours plus euh
mais je vais all arriver sur le sujet
euh on fait toujours on peut faire
toujours plus mais pareil donnez-moi un
exemple d'un moment dans l'histoire de
notre école on a autant réinvesti sur
l'éducation prioritaire il y a 500000
élèves qui font leur rentrer dans des
classes des doublé il y a des millions
d'élèves qui ont un un petit déjeuner
gratuit mais il y a de l'éducation
prioritaire en ruralité aussi évidemment
heureusement et par ailleurs il y a
aussi beaucoup de pas beaucoup mais on
prend aussi d'autres mesures mais madame
oui vous allez y revenir sur les langues
régionales moi je le dis et je le dis
d'autant plus que je sais que c'est un
message qui n'a pas toujours été porté
au niveau ministériel dans ce ministère
je soutiens les langues régionales et
leur apprentissage je l'assume et je les
soutiens d'autant plus qu'ell permettent
souvent et parfois d'améliorer
l'apprentissage du français je vous
donne un exemple je me suis rendu à la
Réunion
à la Réunion à la Réunion vous avez 85 %
des élèves qui parlent créole à la
maison bah la meilleure manière
d'apprendre à l'école c'est quand même
qu'on qu'il puisse entendre du créole à
l'école il y a une expérimentation qui a
été menée dans des maternelles ils ont
pris des classes de maternelle 100 %
langue française et des classes de
maternelle bilingu créol français à
l'issue de l'évaluation on voit que les
classe de maternelle créole français les
élèves parlent mieux le français que
dans les écoles les classes % français
c'est pour moi un exemple tout à fait
parlant du rôle des langues régionales
comme un pont vers la langue française
et notamment dans nos territoires
ultramarin et pour le reste et pas que
vous avez vu les propos du président de
la République qu' l' a tenu en Corse sur
la mise en place d'un service public de
l'apprentissage de la langue corse je
souhaite qu'on puisse accéder c'est
aussi une part de notre culture de notre
histoire compris régionale qui doit
pouvoir être transmise à nos enfants
enfin Madame descan je vous avais
répondu un peu par anticipation tout à
l'heure voilà j'essayie d'être le plus
rapide possible madame la Présidente
mais je suis sûr que j'ai répondu par
anticipation à beaucoup de questions des
des
députés
merci ah oui pardon pardon mais je vais
vous répondre madame
Carel très madame Carel madame Carel on
a bien entendu mais en fait non non mais
c'est pas ça c'est juste une question
pratique c'est si vous ne parlez pas
dans le micro on s'est pas enregistré et
c'est pas entendu donc
et c'est très important que toutes les
questions puissent être prises et au
elles vont y être répondu mais comme je
l'avais indiqué en préambule monsieur le
ministre on va prendre à nouveau les les
questions et on répondra sur toutes les
autres questions ensuite et même mais si
on répond comme vous le souhaitez bien
sûr mais j'avais j'avais dit qu'on
approfondirait les questions si jamais
c'était pas répondu monsieur le ministre
allez-y effectivement madame Carelle
vous aviez parlé du PACT et je n'ai pas
répondu voilà et donc je vous prie de
m'en excuser je corrige tout de suite
cette très grave erreur
euh le PACT enseignant se
déploie j'aurais une prochaine un
prochain bilan du recours au pacte au
retour des vacances de la toussin à ce
stade je dispose d'un retour partiel du
21 septembre moment où une grande partie
des enseignants n'avaient pas encore
signé leurs états de service et donc
indiqué s'ils adhérent au Pact ou pas de
ce retour partiel du 21 septembre qui
n'est que partiel un enseignant sur qu a
rejoint le PACT c'est un sur TR au
collège et un sur TR en lycée
professionnel donc je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse parler
d'échec d'accord mais je le dis je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse parler d'échec
maintenant il faut qu'on
poursuive beaucoup du pacte du recours
au Pact je le vois dépend des protocoles
signés dans les établissements scolaires
sur l'organisation du remplacement de
courte durée au fond ce que vous disent
les enseignants quand vous échangez avec
eux je peux les je l'entends
parfaitement on ne veut pas en signant
le PACT devenir quelque part
d'astreinte on peut nous appeler à
minuit pour venir faire un remplacement
le lendemain à 8h du matin alors que
normalement on travaille pas le
lendemain évidemment ça n'a jamais été
l'objet du pacte c'est pour ça que dans
chaque établissement doit être signé un
protocole et vous avez ensuite plein de
façons de mettre en place ce protocole
j'ai été dans un établissement par
exemple il demande aux enseignants par
avance des créneaux sur lesquels ces
enseignants estiment qu'ils pourront
faire du remplacement il prévoi un délai
de prévenance en disant on ne peut vous
solliciter que
jusqu'à 48 he avant voilà ou si on vous
sollicite après vous pouvez dire non
c'est des exemples comme ça il y a
d'autres établissements où vous avez des
ch d'établissement qui ont dit aux
enseignants on vous donne on donne un
tableau et vous vous inscrivez à
l'avance sur des créneaux et quand ça
fait 18h vous êtes en Pact voilà je
pense que moi je suis pour donner aussi
beaucoup de souplesse au terrain vous
savez au chefs d'établissement en lien
avec les équipes et je suis sûr que
c'est comme ça qu'on gagne la confiance
y compris sur un dispositif pour lequel
je sais que la confiance est toujours à
bâtir et à construire mais je ne suis
pas jeis je suis pas du genre à
abandonner compris sur ces
sujets merci Monsieur le Ministre donc
maintenant je vais vous donner la parole
à tous ceux qui l'ont demandé mais pour
une minute et je seraai très
intransigente puisque nous avons plus
d'une trentaine d'inscrits Fabrice l
viigoureux merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je souhaite moi
aussi saluer l'effort budgétaire
considérable accordé à notre éducation
nationale pour 2024 une évolution plus
forte en 2 ans que durant chaque bloc de
5 année des trois mandatures précédentes
cet effort il se déploie notamment vous
l'avez dit monsieur le ministre pour
l'éducation prioritaire avec
l'achèvement du dédoublement des classes
de grande setion de CP de CE1 pour des
mesures comme le 8h 18h pour la création
de très petites sections mais il y a
toutefois pour l'éducation prioritaire
une grande attente celle de la révision
d'une carte très datée qui n'intègre pas
les évolutions sociologique d'un certain
nombre d'établissements je pense au
collège Dunois quand avec un IPS
d'environ 80 classé ni en Rep ni en Rep
plus alors qu'un collège voisin avec une
sociologie moins défavorable et un IPS
plus élevé est classé en Rep plus je me
fais le relais de leur formidable équipe
pédagogique pour vous demander à quelle
échéance la carte de l'éducation
prioritaire sera révisée réactualisée
car ce collège duun nois comme d'autres
en France j'en suis convaincu doiv
reveler au plus vite de l'éducation
prioritaire je vous remercie Julie
lechanteux merci madame la Présidente
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais évidemment exprimer notre
solidarité avec la famille les collègues
et les proches de Dominique Bernard
lâchement assassiné il y a quelques
jours à haras j'adresse mon soutien
total à la communauté éducative l'école
est le lieu où s'émancipe l'individu et
rayonne le savoir elle est devenue une
cible la France est ce pays où on peut
mourir d'enseigner attentat après
attentat nous déplorons les mêmes morts
les mêmes failles les mêmes modes
opératoires et ensuite rien ne se passe
qu'on fait votre gouvernement et vos
prédécesseurs depuis la mort de Samuel
paatti pour protéger les enseignants et
les élèves combien faudra-t-il
d'enseignants égorgés comme Samuel Patti
et Dominique Bernard pour que vous
débarrassiez l'école de ceux qui
quotidiennement la défie au nom des
fondamentalistes islamistes
qu'attendez-vous pour allouer un budget
sécurité à l'éducation nationale et
mettre un terme à la politique du pas de
vague qui laisse prospérer l'idéologie
islamiste à l'école je vous remercie
merci gradiier la
melkur merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre euh je tiens à vous
remercier pour votre engagement que je
sais plein et entier dans un contexte
difficile et donc je je tiens aussi à
apporter mon soutien à toute la
communauté éducative d'aras et au-delà
député du Finistère ou un élève sur deux
est scolarisé dans un établissement
privé sous contrat et courapporteur
comme vous le savez d'une mission
d'information relative à l'adaptation de
l'école aux enjeux climatiques je
souhaite aujourd'hui vous interroger sur
le financement de la rénovation des
bâtis scolaires des écoles privées sous
contrat en effet alors que 500 millions
d'euros par an seront débloqués dans ce
budget par le biais du fond vert pour la
rénovation des établissements publics la
loi empêche aujourd'hui tout
accompagnement financier de l'État pour
les investissements sur le bâti scolaire
pour nos écoles
privées l'urgence écologique pourtant
ell ne s'arrêtent pas à leur PES
pensez-vous donc monsieur le ministre
qu'il est nécessaire de trouver les
moyens d'accompagner les écoles privées
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
Jérôme
Legavre oui merci monsieur le ministre
vous avez e titre dit et répéter la
nécessité impérieuse de protéger l'école
on ne peut évidemment qu'être d'accord
encore faut-il mettre en concordance les
discours et les acte monsieur le
ministre je citerai un exemple précis
les enseignants du lycée Henri Sellier
de Livri Gargan dans ma circonscription
en scène saint-ni ont exercé ces deux
derniers jours leur droit de retrait il
manque de tout il n'y a pas de lieu de
rassemblement sécurisé en cas d'incendie
les effectifs augmentent toujours plus
dans certains cours il n a ils sont
obligés de déménager des tables pour
asseoir les élèves il manque de
personnel aesh et psien le lycée
accueille toujours plus d'élèves il n'y
a pas de CPE pas d'AED pas de proviseur
adjoint supplémentaire ni d'infirmière
supplémentaire ni de secrétaire
supplémentaire cette situation
malheureusement n'est pas exceptionnelle
voici ce qu'écrit le syndicat effo des
chefs d'établissement dans une lettre
qu'il vous a adressé les collègues ne
pourront pas à la fois assurer la
priorité de la situation qui s'impose à
tous et l'ensemble des priorités affiché
par l'institution monsieur le ministre
annulerez-vous les 2693 suppressions
d'emploi d'enseignant Pr au budget et au
lieu d'imposer via le pacte merci
monsieur le député j'ai pas eu le temps
mais vous aurez deviné Maxime minot
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre un des vecteurs de la cohésion
sociale et de mixité est le sport la
triste actualité nous montre que cette
cohésion est plus que jamais nécessaire
en tant que co-président du groupe de
travail chargé du suivi de la
préparation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 je constate
la place essentielle du sport auprès des
jeunes notamment auprès des jeunes des
zones en difficulté à presè que 204 80
jours des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 il est plus que
nécessaire que l'éducation nationale se
saisisse pleinement de cet événement
pour redonner une impulsion dans la
pratique du sport auprès des jeunes vous
en avez parlé dans votre propos
liminaire notamment sur l'organisation
des infrastructures sportives qui sont
mises en place dans le budget sport j'ai
deux question ma première question
monsieur le ministre quelle place cette
hausse du budget de votre ministère
réserve-t-il à la pratique du sport et
une question plus pragmatique sur la
rentrée 2024 pendant les Jeux
paralympiques notamment la rentrée
va-t-elle être décalée et pour les
établissements scolaires dans le
périmètre du village des athlètes a-t-on
une indication également pour le
décalage de la rentrée merci monsieur le
député
bertransort merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre j'aimerais
m'arrêter plus particulièrement sur un
objectif très volontariste que vous
portez à travers ce projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 celui qui vise à mieux
rémunérer les professeurs cela est
effectivement nécessaire ainsi il faut
le rappeler 1,9 milliard d'euros sera
consacré à la revalorisation socle et 1
milliard d'euros supplémentair pour la
partie conditionnelle lié à l'exercice
de mission nouvelle je souhaitais saluer
ces mesures le 28 septembre dernier vous
avez annoncé monsieur le ministre que 25
% des enseignants étaient engagé dans la
partie conditionnelle du pacte et vous
l'avez rappelé ce soir c'est un bon
début à mes yeux pour une mesure très
pragmatique qui va permettre notamment
de suppler à certaines absences
d'enseignants c'est une demande forte de
nos concitoyens pouvez-vous nous
confirmer monsieur le ministre que tous
les enseignants des collèges et des
lycée quel que soit leur statut sont
bien concernés par le pacte et nous dire
également comment vous comptez agir pour
qu'une part plus importante
d'enseignants s'engage dans ce Pact je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
Julien
aoule merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre l'idéologie
islamiste qui a massacré les professeurs
de la République Dominique Bernard et
Samuel paatti tent de conquérir notre
école depuis bien longtemps face aux
atteintes à la laïcité qui explose vous
avez tenté un semblant de réaction
salutaire avec l'interdiction de
laabilla dans les ententes scolaires
pour autant notre législation
aujourd'hui est incomplète et inefficace
si dans l'enceinte scolaire le port de
signe religieux de tenue religieuse est
interdit il ne l'est pas dans le cadre
scolaire en dehors des enceintes
c'estàdire des activités des cérémonies
et des sorties scolaire cont tenu de
l'entrisme islamiste comp tenu des
dangers qui pèsent sur l'école de la
République pensez-vous qu'il faille
aller plus loin allez-vous aller plus
loin en interdisant le port de signes
religieux et politique dans le cadre
scolaire pour les cérémonies sorties
scolair et tout événement euh qui est en
lien avec l'activité scolaire je vous
remercie merci Estelle folest
oui merci madame la Présidente je crois
que le ministre a répondu en partie à
mon à ma question qui portait
effectivement sur le le déficit de
médecins scolaires euh en particulier
euh évidemment au regard de des
difficultés de nos jeunes aujourd'hui
alors je pense évidemment au cas de cet
élève radicalisé mais aussi au
précédents hein euh à à Saint-Jean de
luuse ainsi qu' a tous les problèmes de
harcèlement enfin bon je balaye un petit
peu largement mais on voit bien quand
même qu'on a un vrai sujet sur le fond
de capacité de l'école à repérer ces cas
difficiles et euh l'augmentation
évidemment de coopération entre la PMI
la médecine de ville les quelques
médecins scolaires qui nous restent
encore quand même permettrai sans doute
de décharger en partie nos professeurs
du rôle qu'on leur donne souvent qui est
de repérer les élèves en difficulté euh
ce serait quand même plus simple s'il
pouv en effet être en coopération avec
des médecins scolaires voilà donc c'est
plus une remarque puisque le ministre a
déjà répondu et je le remercie
d'ailleurs merci Madame la député Inaki
et
chaniz bien merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je me réjouis tout
d'abord de vos propos concernant
l'enseignement des langues régionales
j'espère pouvoir bientôt vous rencontrer
avec l'Office Public de la langue basque
à ce sujet pour revenir à à à mon
intervention pour lutter contre le
harcèlement contre la précarisation
toujours plus importante des familles
contre les les violences intrafamiliales
pour faire face aux enjeux de santé
mentale les établissements ont besoin de
ples médicaux-soaux solides et surtout
présents vous ne pouvez pas l'ignorer
les assistant sociales les infirmières
les psychologues manquent à l'appel dans
de trop nombreux établissements des
établissements d'éducation prioritaire
ou durant ma carrière je n'ai jamais
connu une équipe au complet aux
établissements ruraux comme dans ma
circonscription où l'ensemble du ha
béarne et dépourvu d'assistante sociale
soit une dizaine de collèges et de lycée
vous avez vous-même reconnu à l'instant
le besoin pourtant rien n'est prévu pour
revaloriser ces métiers et recru de
nouveaux professionnels nous portons
deux amendements qui visent au
recrutement de ces personnels et la
revalorisation pardon de 5 %
immédiatement en les adoptant nous
ferions déjà un premier pas vers une
réhabilitation des pôles médicauxsaux
car quand j'étais moi-même syndicaliste
et reçu à l'éducation national on me dit
il faut aller voir du côté de Bercy
merci monsieur le député Christopher
Weissberg qui n Alexis
Corbière merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre
d'abord redire que pour nous les
effectifs des enseignants qui sont
notamment prévus au PLF 2024 baissent un
équivalent temp plein annuel travailler
j'écouterai votre réponse comme un
emploi il y a 1709 emplois supprimés
dans le premer degré 484 dans le second
il manquerait aujourd'hui 11543 emplois
pour revenir seulement au taux
d'encadrement de 2017 ça c'est l'ffet
moi je vais vite il y a beaucoup de
choses dramatiqu mais vous avez fait une
rentrée sur le harcèlement scolaire d'un
certain point de vue vous nous avez à
vos côtés vous avez communiqué fortement
mais dans ce cadre-là nous ne voyons pas
les moyens de débloquer des moyens
significatifs notamment pour votre grand
annonce que serait les cours d'empathie
et je vous redemande on en parlera
demain mais je les explications
concrètes sur les modalités la forme que
prenonc ces cours d'empathie est-ce
qu'ils seront dispensés par des
personnels formés spécifiquement par des
enseignants qui feront des heures
supplémentaires par des intervenants
extérieur par des entreprises privées
beaucoup de questions sur lequel pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de réponse mais
je vous invite pour conclure à une
empathie réelle pour le service
merci monsieur le député Frédéric
meunier merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre alors moi je suis
inquiète parce que je constate depuis 6
ans qu'on nous annonce tous les ans des
augmentations extraordinaires du budget
de l'Éducation nationale et tous les ans
et bien les problèmes sont toujours les
mêmes à savoir l'absence des savoirs
fondamentaux la revalorisation du
personnel pour faire face à la pénuie
l'absence de médecin d'infirmière de
psychologue alors les ministres passent
avec des plans innovants et les
difficultés restent les mêmes je me
demande si au-delà de la question de
moyens ce n'est pas une question du
mieux dépensé et puis j'avais une
question évidemment sur l'enseignement
scolaire en milieu rural à force de se
concentrer que sur les zones urbaines la
jeunesse rurale a totalement été
délaissé en effet aujourd'hui neu des 10
départements les plus touchés par les
difficultés de lecture des Gunes des
jeunes sont des départements ruraux
alors Monsieur le Ministre qu'en est-il
des programmes de l'éducation
prioritaire dans les territoires rurau
pour que les enfants puissent en
bénéficier dans les mêmes conditions que
ceux des grandes villes je vous remercie
merci madame la députée Frédéric
maillot c'est bon mais oui tout à fait
je sais pas pourquoi belkir
badad merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre l'éducation est
pour moi la mère de toutes les bataille
pour que les ingrédients de la défiance
soi substitués par les ingrédients d'une
société de la confiance confiance dans
les autres et confiance dans un avenir
meilleur prenons garde les mêmes mots
conduisent aux mêmes effets certains
cherchent encore à construire l'Union
par sur la peur la peur de l'aut de ce
qui nous est inconnu de ce qui nous
dépasse les trompettes de la discorde
pourrai raisonner à nouveau ma question
porte sur ligne des priorités de ce
budget que la réduction des inégalités
territoriales et l'amélioration de
l'égalité des chances les cordés de la
réussite financé à hauteur de 7,4
millions d'euros sont un exemple concret
ces cordés ont pour but de renforcer
l'ambition scolaire et de soutenir la
poursuite suite d'études dans
l'enseignement supérieur près de 200000
jeunes ont pe bénéficier pardon de ce
dispositif l'an passé monsieur le
ministre comment le ministère compt-ils
évaluer l'impact de ces initiatives sur
la réduction des inégalités
territoriales et l'amélioration de
l'égalité des chances merci monsieur le
député Caroline
Parmentier merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre le 5 septembre
dernier vous déclariez à propos de
l'uniforme il faut passer par des
expérimentations à l'automne je
présenterai des modalités et un
calendrier d'expérimentation dans un
certain nombre d'établissements les
députés du rassemblement national dans
le cadre du PLF 2024 vont dans votre
sens par les différents amendements
qu'ils ont déposé à ce sujet oui il est
temps de procéder à cette
expérimentation le budget de l'Éducation
nationale le permet c'est d'autant plus
nécessaire que des élèves nourris
d'idéologie communautariste défi
toujours plus l'école en se présentant
dans leurs établissements en abaya Islam
on sait que les centaines de
signalements ne sont que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg et que par de
nombreux signalements de nombreux
signalements n'ont pas lieu par crainte
du pas de vague ou par peur des
répercussions et des menaces les
professeurs ont peur en France et on
sait pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre
allez-vous joindre la parole aux actes
allez-vous accepter la main tendue par
les députés du rassemblement national
pour le bien de notre école publique je
vous remercie Fabienne
kbock merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre dans ces moments
tragiques qu' bouleverse l'ensemble de
l'éducation nationale je tiens à vous
assurer monsieur le ministre de toute ma
confiance envers votre action et votre
engagement et je salue les décisions
claires que vous avez prise dès votre
entrée en fonction la mission sur
l'enseignement scolaire connaîtra en
2024 la plus importante progression du
budget de l'État pour un total de 63,6
milliards soit une augmentation de plus
de 6,5 par par rapport à 2023 vous avez
répondu à de nombreuses questions mais
je voulais tout de même vous dire que je
me réjouissais des annonces de ce budget
qui prévoit la création aussi et la
réhabilitation de 3000 places en
internat d'excellence dans les
territoires ruraux d'ici 2026 permettant
ainsi aux jeunes volontaires de
bénéficier d'un d'un accompagnement
pédagogique renforcé et personnalisé et
que c'était très attendu je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre merci
Laurent esken gox merci madame la
Présidente monsieur le ministre messieur
les rapporteurs chers collègues je
m'associe au préalable aux hommages de
ceux qui m'ont précédé vous avez déjà eu
l'occasion monsieur le ministre de le
mentionner la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire et votre priorité
comment ne pourrait pas l'être ne
pourrait-elle pas l'être derrière le
harcèlement se cache des morts ce de
l'INC th ou Luca toutes les enquêtes
montrent que le harcèlement à l'école se
déplace sur les réseaux sociaux selon la
dgsco celle-ci concerne 25 % des
collégiens qui ont connu des atteintes
VI les nouvelles technologies or l'école
contribue à donner aux élèves l'accès
aux outils du numérique avec des
tablettes des ordinateurs offerts par
exemple cet accès public est nécessaire
il permet de réduire les inégalités
surtout il offre à la collectivité la
possibilité d'agir par la
sensibilisation directe mais aussi par
les modalités de conclusion de ce
contrat informatique configuration kit
sur l'harcèlement et cetera à ce titre
une proposition d'amendement que je
porte vise à inscrire dans le code de la
commande publique la possibilité pour
les acheteurs d'inclure dans les
conditions d'exécution d'un marché des
conditions relatives à la lutte contre
l'hcèlement quel est votre avis sur le
sujet je vous remercie merci Cécile
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je souhaiteris revenir sur le
sujet de la formation continue des
enseignants dans un rapport publié le 7
septembre dernier la Cour des comptes
soulignait que la formation continue des
enseignants tout comme la formation
initiale est l'un des principaux leviers
susceptibles d'améliorer à cours et
moyen terme les résultats des élèves
français et le service public
d'enseignement pourtant vous le savez le
temps de formation continue des
enseignants est inférieur à celui de la
moyenne des pays de l'OCDE de sur quoi
un certain nombre de nos enseignants
estiment qu'il n'existe pas de formation
appropriée au besoins qui se manifeste
au cours de leur carrière monsieur le
ministre lre lors de votre audition au
Sénat la semaine dernière vous avez
insisté sur l'impérative de revoir la
formation de nos enseignants de sorte
qu'elle soit adaptée à la réalité au
défis du 21e siècle la prise en charge
des élèves à besoins particulierers le
numérique éducatif la lutte contre le
harcèlement et tant d'autres enjeux
encore nécessit que nos enseignants
bénéficient d'une formation continue
renforcée aussi Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelles sont
les dispositions budgétaires prévues
pour traduire votre volonté
d'amélioration concrète et pérenne pour
la formation continue de nos enseignants
je vous remercie merci Sophie
blanc merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre le 27 septembre
dernier vous annonciez un tsunami de la
parole en parlant du harcèlement
scolaire le programme PHARE débuté en
2021 atteint son plein effet dans les
écoles les collèges puis les lycées et
c'est une bonne chose ce qui me gêne le
plus comme député mais aussi comme
parent d'élèves c'est que quand je
cherche dans votre projet de loi de
finances je ne trouve aucun des
instruments mesure ou d'indicateurs
mesurant sérieusement l'efficacité de
cette grande politique contre le
harcèlement vous restez vague et
généraliste et ce qui peut être
inquiétant votre dgco Édouard Geffry
dans sa présentation stratégique énonce
la lutte contre les violences scolaires
à caractère sexiste sexuel LGBT phobe
raciste et antisémite ces items ne font
pourtant pas partie des indicateurs du
programme 230 VI l'élève alors pourquoi
ne pas les intégré dans ce programme je
vous remercie merci Céline
Calvez merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre hier toute la
communauté éducative s'est tenue debout
pour rendre hommage et la communauté
éducative s'est élargie à celle de tout
un pays parce qu'il faut tout un pays
pour assurer l'ambition éducative
comment pouvoir davantage créer le lien
entre les enseignants et ceux qui font
bouger les cités je pense notamment aux
associations ceux qui veulent cultiver
l'apprentissage de l'altérité je
discutais encore cet après-midi avec tar
Gali et Kati comouson de tout ce qu'il
existe déjà et qui vont dans le bon sens
comment aujourd'hui consacrer plus de
moyens au la complémentarité entre les
enseignants et le tissu associatif j'ai
proposé plusieurs amendements dans le
cadre de C PLF afin de permettre un
fléchage spécifique sur les financements
de l'État qui pourrai venir renforcer et
bien les activités de lien entre les
acteurs associatifs et les enseignants
que que ce soit sur l'orientation sur le
soutien scolaire la laïcité l'empathie
le sport la santé ou encore le
médico-social qu'en pensez-vous merci
merci Isabelle
prigo merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre alors le budget de
votre ministère sera en Haus de 6 et5i %
par rapport à l'an passé et on s'en
réjouit ce qui représente cela a été dit
une hausse historique hein de près de 4
milliards d'euros cependant cette hausse
du budget s'accompagne de la suppression
de 2500 postes d'enseignants à la
rentrée 2024 le ministère justifie cette
suppression par une baisse importante
des effectifs d'élèves en lien avec la
démographie du pays alors l'annonce de
cette nouvelle vague de suppression de
PO fait réagir non sans raison la
communauté éducative et notamment dans
les circonscriptions rurales comme la
mienne en sc etmarne avant la rentrée
2023 vous aviez promis rappelez-vous
qu'il y aurait un professeur devant
chaque classe à la rentrée et dans ma
circonscription le cège les Tournelles
de Villiers Saint-Georges reste sans
enseignant dans les matières physiqu
chimie lettrre classiquees depuis la
rentrée ni même de le conseiller
principal d'éducation ma question est
donc simple monsieur le ministre alors
que votre budget est en hausse et que
vous prévoyez pourtant la suppression de
postees d'enseignant comment allez-vous
faire concrètement pour résoudre ces
problèmes de manque d'enseignant je vous
remerci merci madame la députée violette
pilebou madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je souhaite saluer votre
investissement sans faille auprès de nos
enfants et de la communauté éducative
qui avec notre pays traverse une épreuve
sans précédent nous sommes tous avec les
enseignants et nous les soutenons ma
question porte sur l'éducation au médias
et à l'information au sein du parcours
citoyen et du renforcement de
l'éducation citoyenne à l'école je crois
fermement après la mission parlementaire
que j'ai mené à ce sujet que nous devons
favoriser l'intervention de journalistes
et d'auteurs dans les classes en soutien
à nos professeurs pour travailler avec
les jeunes sur la fabrique de
l'information et ainsi mieux lutter
contre la désinformation le complottisme
les séparatismes et l'embrigadement les
professeurs document sont au cœur de ce
dispositif leur rôle de coordination
doit être mieux reconnu et valorisé les
moyens dédiés à cette éducation média
doivent être renforcés le budget au PLF
2024 permettra-t-il à vos yeux de
relever ce défi dans nos classes je vous
remercie merci madame la députée Bruno
Bild merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre après l'attentat islamiste
d'arace et alors que la menace
terroriste est très élevée la sécurité à
l'intérieur et au abord des
établissements scolaires est une
priorité absolue l'école doit demeurer
un sanctuaire protégé contre les
violences extérieur les collectivités
locales sont compétentes en ce concerne
les abords des établissements scolaires
mais les moyens financiers et humains
sont insuffisants pour déployer des
agents de police municipale devant
chaque école collège et lycée elles ne
peuvent pas non plus assumer seul les
travaux urgents de sécurisation qui
s'imposent la sécurisation
des écoles exige une mobilisation
conjointe des collectivités locales et
des services de l'État monsieur le
ministre quel dispositif précis
envisagez-vous en lien avec le ministre
de de l'intérieur pour renforcer
efficacement la sécurité aux abords des
établissements scolaires je vous
remercie merci Philippe
Berta oui merci présidente monsieur le
ministre ravi de vous retrouver dans
notre commission tout particulièrement
ces temps où notre école laïque et
menacé je souhaite à ce titre vous
alerter et vous questionner sur la
culture scientifique de nos élèves qui
dit laïcité dit connaissance et savoir
fondamentaux des faits démontrés
jusqu'au développement de l'esprit
critique je vous su particulièrement
engagé sur l'enseignement du français
des mathématiques et je suis vous et je
vous en suig gré toutefois les
mathématiques ne représentent pas les
sciences les sciences permettent de
sititer notre évolution humaine notre
place au sein de la biosphère et même au
sein de l'univers observable elles sont
des rempars au complotisme et autes
négationnisme pourant le niveau
scientifique général des élèves chutent
dramatiquement pour exemple les élèves
français en fin de CM1 figurent
désormais en avant-dernière position des
pays de l'OCDE aussi Monsieur le
Ministre pourriiez-vous s'il vous plaît
nous dire quelles mesures urgentes
comptez-vous prendre afin de redonner
aux sciences toute leur place dans
l'enseignement scolaire de la maternelle
au lycée merci Emmanuel
Antoine monsieur le ministre je souhaite
revenir sur la suppression de postees
d'enseignant dans le second degré en vue
de la rentrée scolaire de septembre 2024
vous prévoyez de supprimer 484 emplois
d'enseignants dans le second degré après
en avoir déjà supprimé plus de 3100
depuis 2020 ces suppressions de postes
sont intervenues alors qu'en même temps
nous observions une croissance des
effectifs scolarisés dans le secondaire
ces choix de votre ministère interroge
tant ils apparaissent préjudiciables à
la qualité des conditions d'enseignement
des postes d'enseignant vont ainsi être
supprimés dans certaines matières ce qui
va contraindre leurs collègues à assurer
un nombre excessivement élevé d'heur
supplémentaires et il sera en outre plus
difficile d'organiser des temps
d'enseignement en effectif alléger en
dépit des injonctions en ce sens et la
Cour des comptes dans un rapport
d'octobre 2020 à pointé du doigt le
recours accru aux heures supplémentaires
dans la fonction publique dont le coût
est d'ailleurs sousévalué et dans son
analyse du budget 2020 l'institution
observait que les enseignants du second
degré réalisent près de 600000 heures
supplémentaires hebdomadaire statistique
au plus haut depuis 20 ans alors ne
faut-il pas revenir sur ces choix ma
p afin d'assurer la qualité
desenseign Francis
Dubois monsieur le ministre projet de
loi des finances 2024 traduit une un
budget en Haus de pour l'éducation
nationale ces efforts budgétaires
permettront-ils de relever le niveau des
élèves français qui stagnent en queue
des classements internationaux sur ce
point les territoires ruraux ne sont pas
épargnés et sont désormais fortement
touché par cette baisse de niveau
l'exemple sur ma circonscription
corésienne les suppressions de postes où
les absences d'enseignants non remplacés
se multiplient et les classes multin
niiveau deviennent la norme dans six
écoles sur 10 l'ensemble des classes
sont à multiples niveaux ces décisions
ont des répercussions néfastes sur la
qualité de l'enseignement dispensé sur
l'apprentissage des élèves leur niveau
scolaire en Patil les lacunes
s'accumulent sans compter les temps de
trajets importants pour rejoindre les
établissements scolaires 6 élèves sur 10
sont aujourd'hui scolarisés hors de leur
commune de résidence les journées sont
bien trop longues pour les enfants
maintenir les écoles de proximité est
essentiel pour leur apprentissage et
leur épanouissement monsieur le ministre
il faudrait-il pas intégrer le milieu
rural en zone d'éducation prioritaire
pour permettre un meilleur encadrement
et ainsi relever le niveau scolaire de
nos jeunes les écoles rurales ne peuvent
être les oubliés de la République merci
monsieur le député Christine
Loire merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre alerté sur mon
territoire par des parents d'élèves en
situation de handicap je tenais à vous
faire part de nos préoccupations
partagées cet article le 53 du PLF
prévoit en effet de donner tout pouvoir
à l'éducation nationale pour déterminer
et évaluer les besoins si spécifiques de
ses élèves mission assurée aujourd'hui
par la MDPH en évaluant les besoins de
l'enfant de manière précise et
individuelle le projet personnalisé de
scolarisation garanti le parcours et
l'accompagnement de l'enfant en milieu
au sein de l'école pardon lors de son
discours à la conférence nationale du
handicap le 26 avril dernier le
président Macron appelait de ses vœux
que l' handicap selon ses mots de devait
cesser d'être dans le silence que chacun
soit entendu haut et fort alors oui
monsieur le ministre entendez le cri
d'alerte des parents d'enfants en
situation de handicap retirreer cet
article les parents n'en veulent pas
retirreer ce pôle d'appui à la scolarité
car il car ils s'annonce pour les
parents en détresse comme une immense
pas en
arrière merci Valérie Bazin
malgra merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre l'école de la
République transmet les savoirs et
favorise l'égalité des chances l'égalité
des chances c'est ce dont il est
question dans mon intervention
aujourd'hui en effet lors de l'audition
du dgco dans cette commission il a
indiqué que la refondation de la carte
des r plus n'interviendrait pas avant
2025 alors qu'elle était attendue et
espérée pour 2024 j'aimerais attirer
votre attention sur le collège des
Jacobins dans ma circonscription ce
collège où le taux de boursier est
supérieur à celui des collèges de REP
plus ce collège situé dans un quartier
où l'indice de position sociale est de
68 le plus bas de tout tout le
département de l'Aube dans le quartier
julged qui fait malheureusement partie
des 20 quartiers les plus pauvres de
France Monsieur le Ministre la
relégation en 2025 d'une éventuelle
classification en r plus suscite
l'incompréhension du corps enseignant
des élèves et des parents j'aimerais
savoir Monsieur le Ministre quand vous
allez classer les Jacobins en r plus
merci merci monsieur le ministre c'est à
vous pour répondre à cette série de
questions complémentaires certaines vous
y avez déjà répondu et d'autres sont
nouvelles
merci madame la Présidente il y a pas de
problème mesdames et messieurs les
députés euh pour répondre d'abord à
Monsieur le vigoureux mais ça répondra
aussi à Madame Bazin malgrass qui vient
de d'en parler oui il va falloir réviser
la carte de l'éducation prioritaire et
en réalité ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on en parle c'est un peu devenu un
serpent de mer mais un moment il faut le
faire il faut le faire en lien avec la
révision de la carte des qpv je pense
que c'est aussi pour ça que le ministère
a attendu parce que il faut que les deux
soient liés entre politique de la ville
et éducation prioritaire donc je ne sais
pas si ce sera à compé de 2024 ou
2025 mais évidemment on le fera ça
nécessite des concertations locales en
l'état actuel si on applique les
critères actuels de l'éducation
prioritaire aux établissements ça
voudrait dire qu'il y a 200
établissements qui entreraient en
éducation prioritaire et 200 qui en
sortirai beaucoup plus simple d'en faire
rentrer que d'en faire sortir évidemment
ce qui nécessite beaucoup de
concertation peut-être de réinterroger
aussi certains critères en attendant
vous le savez on a des outils depuis
2021 un outil qui est notamment le CLAS
le contrat local euh d'accompagnement
pour accompagner les écoles orphelines
vous avez décrit des euh exemples quand
une école ou un collège est à faible euh
IPS indice de position sociale mais
n'est pas rattaché à R pour r plus là on
peut mettre des moyens supplémentaires
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi tjours
qu' ce travail moi en tout cas je le
demande à mes rectrices et mes recteurs
qui ce travail très fin qui soit fait au
niveau des établissements madame euh le
Chanteau euh sur euh chante le don le
Chanteux excusez-moi
sur sur la sécurisation des
établissements je l'ai dit j'ai vu les
organisations syndicales ce matin
longuement je verrai demain les
associations d'élus vous le savez c'est
un c'est une compétence des
collectivités locales pour autant je ne
me défausse pas devant mes
responsabilités si on doit financer des
choses pour permettre le financement des
collectivités locales on le fera
important encore une fois c'est la
sécurité des élèves des personnels et
souvent il y a différentes compétences
entre l'État les collectivités local
mais les Français eux font pas tout à
fait la différence évidemment dans les
responsabilités et ils ont raison ils
attendent que collectivement on soit en
mesure de leur apporter le meilleur
service public possible et qui soit en
sécurité depuis 2 17 on a dépensé 100
millions d'euros pour des établissements
publics locaux sur la sécurisation on va
continuer à le faire mais il faut que je
vois les associations d'élus pour
qualifier les besoins ce qui a été fait
depuis 2015 par y a eu beaucoup de
travaux qui ont été faits depuis 2015
des régions qui se sont engagées sur le
sujet certaines sur des portiques
d'autres sur des caméras de vidéo
protection certaines sur des posts de
vigile supplémentaires je pense qu'il
faut regarder toutes les solutions je
pense que l'essentiel c'est que on
garantisse un niveau minimum un standard
minimum qui est que on ne doit pas
pouvoir s'introduire dans un
établissement scolaire quand on n pas
ass
introduire et sans être contrôlé et ça
malheureusement aujourd'hui j'ai
conscience que ce n'est pas le cas
partout qu'il a encore des brèches et
c'est pour ça qu'on doit très vite les
combler même s'il a aussi beaucoup a été
fait madame Melchor sur la rénovation du
bâti privé oui je vous confirme que la
loi ne permet pas aujourd'hui à l'état
de la financer cela relève des ojec les
organismes de gestion de l'enseignement
catholique qui je crois notamment vont
pouvoir le faire via leur fond de
roulement monsieur Legavre vous m'avez
abordé la question des postes notamment
de PSI euh on a 8500 personnels
aujourd'hui contre près de 9000 en
2018-209 pour la la session 2023 200
postes ont été ouverts au concours
externe c'est stable par rapport à 2022
50 postes au concours interne c'est
stable aussi et 10 postes ce qui est
stable aussi au 3è concours monsieur
minot vous m'avez interrogé sur
plusieurs sujets d'abord évidemment le
sport je sais que vous soutenez beaucoup
la pratique sportive à l'école et vous
avez raison on continue à la renforcer
il y a les 30 minutes d'activé
d'activité physique quotidienne en
primaire mme si je sais qu'il y a encore
du travail pour que ça puisse être fait
partout euh il y a ensuite
l'expérimentation des 2 heures de sport
en plus au collège qui se poursuit euh
et qui sera expérimenté dans 700
collèges cette année notamment en qpv au
total c'est 5,7 milliards d'euros de
budget pour le PS dans le PLF 2024
essentiellement bien sûr c'est le
salaire des profs de PS mais ça finance
tout cela vous m'avez demandé monsieur
Mino s'il fallait reporter la rentrée
2024 du fait des Jeux Olympiques dans
les établissements concernés non
évidemment mais on cherchera à trouver
des adaptations j'ai vu encore récemment
le président du Département de sens
monsieur Troussel il faut qu'on trouve
des solutions au cas par cas je suis
très attentif au bon fonctionnement des
établissements scolaires et donc à plus
forte raison à ne pas empêcher la
rentrée depuis plusieurs mois des
travaux minutieux de recensement des
écoles et des établissements situés à
proximité des lieux d'épreuves a été
effectué par les services des rectorats
en lien avec les collectivités locales
c'est des travaux qui sont toujours en
cours avec les préfectures et la
préfecture de police pour ajuster au
plus près la liste les établissements
pour lesquels des aménagements seront
nécessaires selon qu'il se situe dans un
périmètre de circulation interdit
interdite restreinte ou à proximité des
voies réservées on travaille donc à
lever chacun des obstacles
anticipés mais on suivra les choses au
cas par cas monsieur sort je vous
confirme que tous les enseignants
peuvent bien être concernés par le PCT
s'il le souhaite y compris les
contractuels on va continuer à
convaincre pour qu'il y ait de plus en
plus d'enseignants qui s'y engagent il y
a des missions je le dis qui sont
fondamentales pour nos élèves notamment
l'aide au devoir et qui constituent un
effort financier important pour des
enseignants qui effectuent déjà ces
missions il y a beaucoup d'enseignants
qui font des ades du remplacement de
courte durée en moyenne 2 heur par
semaine c'est payé 41 € brut de l'heure
aujourd'hui ça passe à 69 € brut de
l'heure via le PACT plus 50 %. idem plus
50 % sur les devoir fait idem pour les
enseignants qui font des stages de
réussite pendant les vacances ils sont
40000 chaque année à le faire accueillir
des élèves ils sont payés 27 € de
l'heure ça passe à 52 € de l'heure avec
le PACT donc ce Pact il vient aussi
mieux rémunérer des missions qui sont
déjà effectués par beaucoup
d'enseignants que je remercie par
ailleurs monsieur Odoul m'avait
interrogé sur la question des signes
religieux pour les les les
accompagnateurs en l'occurrence
accompagnatrice de sortie scolaire c'est
un vrai débat eu je suis parfaitement
transparent avec vous c'est un débat sur
lequel j'ai beaucoup réfléchi je me suis
beaucoup interrogé sur cette question
personne ne peut nier euh mon engagement
absolu pour la laïcité à l'école euh je
pense l'avoir témoigné avec une décision
importante sur le port de la baaya et du
camis à la rentrée dont beaucoup
disaient qu'elle était soit impossible à
prendre sont impossiblebl à faire
appliquer résultat des courses je l'ai
prise et elle est aujourd'hui appliquée
partout donc je suis très clair sur ces
questions là on n'est pas dans l'école
ce qui a fini par me convaincre c'est
une tribune que j'ai pu lire sur
Internet vous pouvez lire qui est une
tribune qui s'appelle pour le droit des
mères voilé accompagner les sorties
scolaires avec toute une argumentation
pour expliquer pourquoi est-ce que quand
bien même on est un ardent défenseur de
la laïcité à l'école on peut défendre la
possibilité pour les mares d'accompagner
les sorties scolaires en leur foul cette
tribune est signée par Caroline Fourest
qu'on ne peut pas accuser de tergiverser
avec la laïcité que ce soit à l'école ou
dans la société et donc c'est cette
tribune qui a achevé de me convaincre
que je ne modifierai pas les règles en
la matière même si j'entends
parfaitement le débat et il est tout à
fait légitime qui peut avoir lieu sur le
sujet ça fait des années qu'il existe
mais en l'occurrence j'assume mes
décisions et je pense qu'il y a déjà
suffisamment de travail avec ce qui se
passe au sein des établissements
scolaires et dans l'école peut-être
qu'une fois qu'on aura réglé tous ces
sujet là on pourra s'intérer
s'intéresser à ce qui se passe en dehors
euh monsieur corbierre sur les moyens
pour le harcèlement scolaire j'ai donner
un chiffre dans mon intervention euh
liminire mais évidemment on va continuer
à poursuivre sur les cours d'empathie
vous avveit posé la question euh il y a
d'abord des enseignants qui pourronter
réaliser avec une formation pour cela
euh il y a à la fois la méthode danoise
que je suis allé voir qui est déjà
utilisé aujourd'hui dans des
établissements scolaires parisiens ou à
saint-toouin par exemple il y a aussi
des associations des fondations qui ont
des méthodes extrêmement intéressantes
je pense qu' je pense à la Fondation SEV
de du philosophe Frédéric Lenoir qui
fait des ateliers à Visé philosophiqu en
primaire c'est absolument remarquable ce
qui est fait je soutiens beaucoup ces
initiatives et on pourrait tout à fait
s'appuyer dessus pour déployer
l'apprentissage de l'altruisme de
l'altérité de la tolérance à l'école
monsieur béadad vous m'avez interrogé
sur les cordés de la réussite 7,4
million d'euros permettent de renforcer
l'ambition scolaire vous l'avez dit
200000 élèves en ont bénéficié l'an
passé j'ai fixé pour objectif que 100 %
des collèges REP REP plus soi encordés
cette année et oui nous
l'expérimenterons madame Parmentier vous
m'avez interrogé sur les tenues
scolaires et l'uniforme vous avez
rappelé que je me suis engagé à annoncer
la manière dont je souhaiteraai
l'expérimenter à l'automne nous sommes
toujours à l'automne il court encore
quelques
semaines donc je m'exprimerai sur le
sujet à l'automne comme je m'y suis
engagé je pense pas qu'il soit
nécessaire de prévoir des crédits en PLF
sur le sujet mais en tout cas j'entends
bien l'intention partagé par beaucoup de
groupes parlementaires d'avancer dans
cette direction ça fait des années que
c'est un débat là aussi qui existe des
années que souvent le discours politique
consiste à dire si les établissements
souhaitent le faire ils peuvent le faire
mais en réalité aucun ne le fait jamais
donc là moi j'assume com bien même
d'ailleurs j'ai pas une position
totalement arrêtée sur le sujet je pense
comme beaucoup de Français j'ai besoin
de voir à l'œuvre l'expérimentation pour
mesurer si c'est utile ou pas mais
j'assume d'organiser du coup une
expérimentation d'ampleur et je suis en
échange en ce moment avec les
associations d'élus avec par ailleurs
des élus qui souhaitent que
l'expérimentation ait lieu dans des
établissements de leur commune et
j'appelle des si vous avez des élus
locaux dans vos circonscriptions qui
souhaitent l'expérimenter à me le faire
savoir qu'on puisse les intégrer à
l'expérimentation madame kbock sur les
internats d'excellence oui 3000 places
seront rénovées ouvertes en internat
d'excellence en zone rurale c'est le
plan France ruralité annoncé par la
première ministre à ce titre 40 millions
d'euros en AE et 100 millions d'euros en
CP dans ce PLF sont prévus donc on
poursuit cet engagement monsieur
esquenet euh sur l'équipement en matière
de harcèlement euh les équipements
individuels de nos élèves vivent à
réduire la fracture numérique et les
inégalités entre les familles les études
de la DEP sur le sujet monent comme vous
le disiez l'impact direct d'un
équipement individuel sur les résultats
scolaires des élèves notamment au
collège en mathématique et dans les
zones d'éducation
prioritaire cependant ces équipements
euh doivent être utilisés dans le cadre
de la classe ou en lien avec une
activité pédagogique donnée par
l'enseignant à la maison comme vous le
savez les règles de commande publique en
terme d'équipement sont vertueuses en
terme du respect du code de l'éducation
des standards français et européens je
ne crois pas que changer cet aspect là
en rillerit le
cyberhcèlement mais évidemment on peut
continuer en débattre madame RAC m'a
interrogé sur la
formationue des enseignants oui c'est un
levier majeur pour améliorer
l'enseignement oui nos enseignants ne se
forment pas assez 1,9 milliards d'euros
dans ce PLF pour la formation je peux
aussi revaloriser les formateurs car
c'est nécessaire j'assume le choix qui
est le mien de dire qu'il faut désormais
que les enseignants se forment en dehors
du temps euh devant élève il y a 2
millions d'heures de cours l'an dernier
qui ont été perdus sans être remplacé du
fait de formation continue d'enseignant
sur temps scolaire je pense que si on
veut élever le niveau il faut éviter les
absences évitables éviter qu'il a des
cours qui sautent et donc j'assume même
si je sais que c'est pas facile et tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord avec ce
choix de dire qu'il faudra désormais se
former pour la formation continue en
dehors du temps devant élève ce qui
nécessite aussi de réinventer la manière
dont la formation est organisée et donc
avec des modules plus courts hybrides
parfois sur site en groupe pour
accompagner les les enseignants dans
leur dans leur formation peut pas dire
qu'aujourd'hui la formation continu se
déploie dans des condition parfaite pour
tout le monde il y a moins d'un
enseignant sur deux au collège qui se
forme c'est à peine plus d'un sur TR au
lycée on voit qu'on doit quand même
améliorer le proposition de formation je
me rends compte que je n'ai pas répondu
à Madame de
corz
euh c'est la seule je crois et je ne
m'étais pas noté ah non madame Antoine
non plus pardon excusez-moi et oui en
fait tous les derniers qui qui staentsur
ministre parceen fait j'avais arrêté de
noter parce qu'on était à la fin et tout
à fait et vous aurez aussi une question
de Monsieur rau qui n'avait pas Madame
blanc était intervenue sur le
harcèlement également pardon en fait je
pense pens que j'étais d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre est-ce qu'on peut
prendre la question de mon collègue
monsieur RA parce que nous l'avions
oublié dans la
liste voilà je pense que ça sera ça
voilà Monsieur R le micro hop je vous le
donne coupr merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre il y a
les grands moments de réunion les
moments comme vous l'appeliez samedi de
de vos vœux monsieur le ministre où la
République toute entière fait bloc
autour de l'école et de son corps
olori et puis quand le temps sera passé
il restera le cotidien mais la douleur
elle ne passera pas elle ne peut pas
passer parce qu'on ne peut pas l'oublier
elle ne peut pas passer car elle est
installée depuis bien longtemps au cœur
de la profession le sentiment d'être
déconsidéré le sentiment d'être une
d'abord au sens figuré puis au sens
propre avec les destins tragiques de
Samuel Patier de Dominique Bernard et le
sentiment d'être abandonné abandonné
parce qu'il faut toujours colmater les
brèches déconsidérer quand on pointe du
doigt les professeurs comme s'ils
manquaient à leur mission ciblé qu'en
face à la violence il a pu arriver qu'il
ou elle ne soit pas suffisamment soutenu
par leur administration donc je voudrais
m'assurer monsieur le ministre de ce que
vous allez mettre en œuvre dans la durée
pour que ces sentiments ne soient plus
jamais partagés parmi les personnels de
L' ucation nationale et encore merci
merci monsieur le député monsieur le
ministre donc une question
supplémentaire mais vous pouvez
reprendre le fil de vos réponses je
reprends pour répondre à Madame Meier on
peut pas dire que l'école rurale soit
délaissée il y a au contraire un
renforcement des moyens alloués à
l'école rurale le taux d'encadrement y
est plus favorable qu'au niveau national
il s'établi à 20,3 élèves par classe en
rurale isolé à 21 dans les autres
communes rurales c'est plus en moyenne
au niveau euh national dans l'école
rurale il faut le dire aussi on réussit
bien je pense c'est important d'envoyer
aussi ce message pour les élèves et pour
les familles les évaluations en moyenne
montrent une meilleure performance sur
les fondamentaux jusqu'à la fin du
collège qu'en moyenne sur tout le
territoire national ce qui n'exclut pas
des difficultés dans certains
départements évidemment et moi la
consigne que j'ai donné à mes rectrices
et mes recteurs c'est de piloter leurs
moyens académique aussi en fonction des
résultats des évaluations maintenant on
sait en CP CE1 CM1 6e 4e seconde on a le
niveau de individuel de nos élèves le
niveau par établissement l'irctrice et
les recteurs je leur demande de piloter
leurs moyens académiques évidemment en
fonction de ce qu'on constate aux
évaluations pour élever le niveau de nos
élèves et
donc y compris dans la ruralité quand il
y a des établissements pour lesquels on
constate un niveau qui est moins bon
qu'ailleurs sans qu'on puisse
l'expliquer il faut être capable de
prendre les bonnes mesures et les bonnes
et le bon soutien en moyenne c'est une
étude de la DEP de 2022 en maternelle il
y a en moyenne près de deux élèves par
classe de moins en rural et un élève par
classe de moins en élémentaire je pense
que l'important maintenant pour la
ruralité c'est aussi de donner de la
visibilité on sait que a priori quand on
regarde les naissances dans un
territoire rural ça donne une idée quand
même à peu près du socle minimal de ce
qui arrivera à l'école dans les quelques
années qui suivent et donc on doit être
capable d'avoir cette visibilité donnée
aux élus locaux c'est un des engagements
de la première ministre et donc c'est
important qu'on
puisse évidemment tenir cette
cet
engagement pour pour nos élèves et pour
les familles madame blanc sur le
harcèlement je pense qu' un des outils
utile ça sera ce que je lance pour le 9
novembre la semaine la journée nationale
non au harcèlement avec une grande une
grande enquête qui sera reconduite
chaque année ça permettra d'avoir un
indicateur très concrètement à partir de
la classe de CE2 tous les élèves auront
un questionnaire qu'on a construit avec
des pédopsychiatres des spécialistes de
la santé mentale des enfants de la
violence scolaire notamment le
professeur de Barbieux le professeur
Marcel ruffau madame Nicole Katheline et
d'autres et donc ça je pense que c'est
un outil nouveau sur le harcèlement très
concret qui va nous permettre
d'identifier des situations de
harcèlement qui ne sont pas déclarées
parce que souvent malheureusement des
élèves harcelés en vienne sans s'en
rendre compte à élever leur niveau de
tolérance et à tolérer des choses qui
sont totalement intolérables et donc
c'est important aussi qu' travers ce
questionnaire il puissent se rendre
compte qu'il vivent des situations qui
sont des situations de harcèlement
combien même ils mettent pas ce mot et
parfois on a des situations de
harcèlement qui sont remontées dont on
se rend compte que c'est c'est pas
toujours du harcèlement alors des
problèmes il faut les régler et donc là
je pense que ce questionnaire sera aussi
un appui utile aux équipes de direction
pour objectiver certaines certaines
situations madame priigo vous êtes
intervenu sur la question du manque
d'enseignant oui pour résoudre ce
problème du M d'enseignant il faut
recruter il faut recruter et pour
recruter il faut renforcer
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
c'est l'objet de la concertation que
j'ai ouverte avec les organisations
syndical je souhaite que les
parlementaires puissent y participer il
y a l'attractivité en matière de salaire
maintenant on a en début de carrière un
salaire qui est supérieur à la moyenne
de l'OCDE on a rattrapé un retard fou il
y a 3 ans euh néo tiulaire gagnait 1700
€ net par mois maintenant c'est 2100 €
net par mois c'est 400 € de plus c'est
un sur 3 ans on n jamais vu un telle
revalorisation c'est vrai que du coup on
a concentré beaucoup sur les débuts de
carrière et maintenant les milieux fin
de carrière sur lesquels on doit aussi
agir même si on sait que quand on prend
des mesures qui concernent les
enseignants tout de suite ça coûte très
très cher parce que ils sont 860000 mais
en tout cas on a assumé de prendre ces
décisions sur l'attractivité et je pense
que le levier deattractivité c'est pas
que le salaire c'est la formation le
floit d'avoir positionné le concours à
bac + 5 à assécher les viviers à
entraîner une année de m2 qui est
épuisante pour les étudiants qui cumulle
la préparation du concours les cours
l'alternance la rédaction d'un mémoire
il y en a plein qui abandonnent ou qui
démissionnent euh donc on travaille
aussi sur une réforme profonde de la
formation initiale pour créer les écoles
normales du 21e siècle ce sera
parilleurs utile sur beaucoup d'autres
sujets il y a l'enjeu des conditions
d'exercice du déroulement de carrière
tout ça est sur la table et je pense que
c'est à travers toutes ces mesures qu'on
renforcera l'attractivité monsieur Bild
est revenu sur la question de la
sécurité des établissements donc j'ai
répondu notamment à une autre question
avec le FIPD qui dépend du ministère de
l'Intérieur le fond sur la prévention et
la sécurisation 100 millions d'euros
depuis 2017 évidemment le travail qu'on
va mener avec les collectivités va nous
permettre d'identifier les moyens
supplémentaires pour en déployer le cas
échéant je vois les associations sont
desélus sur sur le sujet
euh sur la question ensuite de Monsieur
Berta sur la question du renforcement du
niveau dans l'ensemble des matières
scientifiques c'est évidemment
fondamental pour garantir l'égalité des
chances aux sein de notre école et
soutenir nos objectifs ambitieux
d'orientation vers les
filières technique et numérique l'école
a un rôle à jouer pour donner à tous les
élèves les clés de compréhension de
notre monde il y a un certain nombre
d'exemples qui sont très bon le
programme chich coporté par l'in ria
prévoit dans le PLF 2024 70000 € pour
des interventions de chercheurs dans des
classes de seconde général pour faire
connaître les métiers du numérique de la
recherche aux élèves on sait que ce qui
fonctionne en matière d'orientation
c'est à la fois l'information mais aussi
l'incarnation et je crois que je crois
beaucoup à tout ce qu'on est en train de
déployer là la demi-journée toutes les
deux semaines de découverte des métiers
au
collège le nouveau stage de fin de
seconde tous ces dispositifs doit
permettre aussi aux élèves de découvrir
un certain nombre de de métiers madame
spbut est intervenue sur l'EMI
l'éducation média et l'information enjeu
majeur pour moi aussi pour le coup à
mettre vraiment dans les priorités de
nouvel enseignement moral et civique la
capacité à décrypter l'information à
laquelle on est confronté notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux pour moi est devenu
un savoir fondamental qu'il faut
connaître pour être un citoyen éclairé
sinon ça deviendra un véritable problème
démocratique si on laisse des élèves
sortir de l'éducation nationale sans
être capable de chercher la source et de
décrypter l'information à laquelle ils
sont confrontés il y a des positif
formidable porté notamment par le cléi
par exemple il faut arriver à
systématiser ça pour que tous les élèves
en en
bénéficient à qui je n'ai pas répondu
maintenant madame Bazin Malgras j'avais
répondu sur l'éducation
prioritaire toujours mais madame Antoine
je ne vous en veux pas vous m'avez
interrogé
sur sur les c'était sur les posts dans
le second degré mais je reprends tout à
l'heure ce qui avait été ce qui avait
été dit par quand on parle des
comparaisons dans le CDE on dépense
toujours moins que les autres pays dans
le premier degré et toujours plus que
les autres dans le second degré donc
vous avez raison je crois que c'est
madameier qui dis ça tout à l'heure il y
a dépenser plus il y a aussi dé penser
mieux maintenant là aussi on a un
problème dans le second degré
aujourd'hui c'est la difficulté à à
remplacer des enseignants qui sont
absents et donc à recruter à pourvoir
toutes nos brigades de remplacement
comme vous je suis très saisi par des
familles des parents d'élèves dont
l'enseignant de lettres de SVT ou autres
est absent pendant plusieurs mois sans
être remplacé parce que la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nos nos brigades de
remplacement elles sont positionnées dès
le début de l'année pour pour voir des
poste en début d'année donc après quand
il y a des absences on a du mal à
remplacer sur la longue durée pour ça
faut qu'on arrive à recruter davantage
ça fait le lien avec ce que je disais à
Madame perriigo sur l'attractivité du
métier plus on rendra ce métier
attractif plus on arri on redonnera
l'attractivité à ce métier plus on
arrivera à recruter moi je ne crois pas
à des crises de une crise des vocations
on a un élève sur 4re qui déclare
envisager de devenir enseignant et on a
des gens de 30 40 50 ans qui ont une
première carrière que ce soit dans le
public ou dans le privé qui disent tous
je veux donner du sens à ma vie donner
du sens à mon travail il y a peu de
travail peu de métiers qui ont autant de
de sens que celui d'enseignant donc moi
je crois pas que c'est une crise
d'évocation c'est une crise
d'attractivité il faut lever les freins
pour attirer toutes ces vocations à
l'école le financier en fait partie je
vous ai donné euh sur les néotitulaires
pour ceux qui ont une première carrière
on a pris des mesures importantes je
trouve qu'ils sont pas suffisamment
connu notamment le fait que maintenant
on reprend les 2/ers de l'ancienneté là
où avant vous démarriez tout en bas euh
maintenant si vous avez une carrière par
exle dans le privé vous décidez de
devenir enseignant reprend 2/3 de votre
ancienneté je pense qu'il y a toujours
une perte évidemment de salaire mais en
tout cas les moins importantes euh moins
importante qu'avant monsieur rau euh sur
la question de de l'autocensure et du
soutien au au aux enseignants c'est un
enjeu on en a parlé au moment des
questions gouvernement structurant
profond je pense d'abord que ça passe
par la réaffirmation de l'autorité des
règles à l'école quand vous devez faire
un cours sur la laïcité et l'application
de la loi de 2004 à l'école si vous avez
en face de vous des élèves qui ne
respectent pas la loi de 2004 en portant
une tenue religieuse évidemment que
c'est compliqué de faire cours sur cette
loi de 2004 donc je pense qu'en
réaffirmant les règles en prenant des
décisions comme je les ai prises à la
rentrée quelque part euh on lutte aussi
contre cette autocensure mais évidemment
on n'est pas au bout du sujet j'ai j'en
ai parlé ce matin avec les organisations
syndicales on va se revoir pour en
parler on s'est notamment interrogé sur
euh enfin moi je leur ai posé la
question puisque des enseignants m'en
ont parlé euh sur le terrain est-ce que
dans certains endroits des enseignants
on voit ça peut être très difficile sur
certains sujets est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer plutôt que d'avoir un
enseignant seul devant sa classe d'avoir
une organisation avec euh peut-être
plusieurs classes plusieurs adultes
peut-être s'appuyer aussi sur des
personnes qui viennent de l'extérieur de
l'établissement on a des formateurs
laïité on a des équipes valeurs de la
République dans les rectorats pour venir
au soutien des enseignants je pense que
tout ça est ouvert mais en tout cas
l'autocensure de nos enseignants c'est
un poison mortel pour notre école il
faut évidemment lutter contre ce
phénomène merci beaucoup à tous et je
suis à votre disposition pour revenir si
je suis réinvité
prochainement
pardon alors est-ce qu'il y en a
d'autres à qui j'ai oublié de répondre
là déjà qu'on soit des journé très long
pour
sur les cétait sur les écoles de
proximité
pourourui on
est c'est
voilà une question qui est importante
évidemment un effort qui est fait
pour supprimer le moins de classes
possible évidemment sur les écoles vous
savez ça maintenant il y a il faut
l'accord du je pense que tout va l'enje
ça va être visibilité qu'on sera capable
de donner comment est-ce qu'on construit
à 3 ans avec les élus locaux un une
carte partagée pour donner de la
visibilité à tout le monde maintenant ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a des y a
toujours des des des des des Français
qui habiteront plus loin que les autres
d'un établissement scolaire et là il y a
tout un travail à mener avec les
collectivités locales sur le transport
scolaire pour améliorer les choses il y
a un travail à mener sur ce qu'on est
capable de proposer aussi aux élèves
dans leurs établissements quand ils y
sont pendant la journée ce qu'on fait
sur le 8h 18h qui va permettre
de d'améliorer et de leur offrir un
certain nombre d'activités culturelles
et sportive en plus je pense que ça sera
utile pour des élèves qui sinon bah
effectivement comme ils passe du temps
dans les transports ils ont pas accès à
toute une partie des activités
périscolaires mais en tout cas je suis
très sensible à cette question que vous
évoquez très ouvert si vous avez des
propositions concrètes en la matière
pour répondre à ce phénomène est-ce que
j'ai oublié quelqu'un d'autre non merci
Monsieur le Ministre alors je réponds à
mon collègue que je ne voulais pas le
censurer mais c'est-à-dire que comme il
n'ait pas son mic ouvert on ne l'entend
pas les ceux qui sont derrière leur leur
écran ne t'entendaient pas c'est pour ça
que d' ma réflex merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre d'avoir pris ce temps de de
venir nous présenter le budget et de
nous apporter les réponses aux questions
qui étaient posées